[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue bonsoir marine le
pen ce soir emmanuel macron christophe
bonsoir l'atelier et bonsoir à tous
bienvenue pour ce débat de l'entre-deux
tours pendant deux heures nous
évoquerons l'économie le terrorisme
l'éducation et l'europe
vous avez aussi souhaité tous les deux
en fin d'émission disposer d'une carte
blanche pour évoquer le thème de votre
choix alors notre rôle sera de veiller
sur la stricte égalité de votre temps de
parole est également à l'écouté de vos
échanges vous pouvez également suivre ce
débat sous titré sur tf1 en france 2 lci
et france info et en langue des signes
sur l'antenne de france info et le site
internet de lci alors le tirage au sort
vous a désigné mme allard marine le pen
pour commencer c'est donc chez emmanuel
macron quiconque le rêve mais avant de
vous intéresser de nous intéresser à vos
propositions une première question après
des mois de campagne à quatre jours du
second tour et à dix jours de votre
investiture si vous êtes élu quel est
votre état d'esprit c'est donc à vous
narrer le pen pas que je suis
extrêmement heureuse de la manière dont
se déroule ce second tour parce que la
réalité c'est que le choix politique les
français vont devoir faire c'est clair
monsieur maquereau et le candidat de la
mondialisation sauvage de libéralisation
de la précarité de la brutalité sociale
de la guerre de tous contre tous 2
du saccage économiques notamment de nos
grands groupes du dépeçage de la france
par les grands intérêts économiques du
communautarisme et tout cela piloté par
monsieur hollande 1 qui est à la
manoeuvre maintenant de la manière la
plus claire qui soit monsieur cazeneuve
a même dit je crois que c'est hier ou
avant-hier fait voter dimanche
résolument pour emmanuel macron faites
le avec la fierté de ce que nous avons
accompli et le désir de voir ce que nous
avons accompli se poursuivre bon eh bien
moi face à cela je suis la candidate du
peuple je suis la candidate de la france
tel que nous l'aimons de sa culture de
sa civilisation de son unité je suis la
candidate de la nation qui protège qui
protège nos emplois qui protège la
sécurité de nos compatriotes qui protège
nos frontières qui nous protège face à
la concurrence internationale déloyale
et face à la montée en puissance du
fondamentalisme islamiste et puis somme
toute les français ont aussi pu voir
vrai macron 1 dans cette second tour
la bienveillance a fait place à la
médisance
la stratégie marketing a été reprise en
main par la machine du ps et puis le
sourire étudiés se transforme en rictus
au fur et à mesure des meetings enfant
chéri du système et des élites en
réalité a tombé le masque monsieur
macron voilà c'est bien je trouve que
c'est utile on a vu les choix que vous
avez fait dans ce second tour des choix
qui sont des choix cynique d'utilisation
d'arguments de campagne qui sont honteux
et qui révèle peut-être la froideur du
banquier d'affaires que vous n'avez
probablement jamais cessé d'être donc je
pense que cette période en réalité de
clarification a été profondément utile
aux français pour faire un choix c'est
donc à vous mais le maquereau de nous
donner votre état d'esprit à quelques
jours du coup le temps d'écouté vous
avez démontré que vous n'êtes en tout
cas pas la candidate de l'esprit de
finesse de la volonté d'un débat
démocratique équilibré ouvert merci pour
cette belle démonstration que vous venez
de faire madame le pen je ne m'attendais
pas à autre chose moi je ne vais pas
vous dire que je vous est la véritable
héritière non seulement d'un nom d'un
parti politique du parti politique de
l'extrême droite française
de tous un système qui prospère sur la
colère des français depuis tenté tant
d'années je ne vais pas vous dire que
vous revendiquez même cet héritage
puisque vous l'avez porté depuis que
vous avez repris ce parti est que depuis
40 ans dans ce pays nous avons des le
pen qui sont candidats à l'élection
présidentielle parce que ça ne
m'intéresse pas alors vous allez
continuer votre logorrhée puisque c'est
ce que vous faites à longueur de
rassemblements et autres la question qui
est posée aujourd'hui à nos concitoyens
c'est de savoir s'ils veulent l'esprit
de défaites que vous portez ce que ce
que vous portez c'est l'esprit des fêtes
c'est d'expliquer à nos concitoyens
c'est trop dur la mondialisation pour
nous c'est trop dur l'europe donc on va
se replier on va fermer les frontières
on va sortir de l'euro sortir de
l'europe parce que les autres y arrive
mais pas nous c'est l'esprit des fêtes
dans la lutte contre le terrorisme
parce que cette lutte tous les pays
développés l'ont toutes les démocraties
ont à la conduire mais vous vous dites
non on va encore là aussi sortir
remettent les frontières comme avant
comme 6 à régler le problème mais nous y
reviendrons face à cet esprit de défaite
moi je porte l'esprit de conquête
français parce que la france a toujours
réussi ehret toujours réussi dans le
monde parce qu'elle est au monde sa
langue elle se parle sur tous les
continents son histoire sa civilisation
ce qui fait sa force c'est précisément
qu'elle rayonne partout ce qui fait que
nous sommes aujourd'hui la cinquième
puissance économique mondiale c'est que
nous sommes forts dans le monde il y as
énormément de changements à faire
énormément ce sont ceux là que je veux
conduire et c'est l'incapacité des
gouvernements depuis tant et tant
d'années pour le 30 ans je n'ai jamais
été ni premier ministre ni président de
la république madame le pen je vais
faire le maximum pour remédier à cela
mais ces changements profonds que je
souhaite qu'ils m'ont conduit quand
j'étais ministre à quitter le
gouvernement c'est bien cela que je
compte mener à leur terme pour que cet
esprit de conquête triomphe c'est ça la
france que je veux c'est ça la france
qui nous ressemble pas la vôtre alors je
vous propose d'aller au fond dès le
début et on va passer à l'économie était
d'abord au chômage alors marine le pen
vous vous considérez que le code du
travail n'est pas un frein à l'embauché
vous voulez abroger la loi elle
conneries vous emmanuel macron vous
voulez réformer le marché du travail et
dès cet été par ordonnance alors les
manuels on vous avez la parole pour
expliquer votre propos votre projet le
problème de la france depuis 30 ans
c'est le taux de chômage nous sommes
dans le chômage de masse depuis 30 ans
nous sommes le seul pays d'europe qui
n'a pas réussi justement à endiguer cela
10% de chômage un taux de chômage des
jeunes qui est extrêmement important
face à cela il faut donner en
particulier à nos petites et moyennes
entreprises la possibilité de créer
davantage d'emplois d'être plus agiles
de s'adapter aux cycles économiques
c'est pour ça que moi je veux de la
simplicité je devais simplicité d'abord
en créant un droit à l'erreur pour tous
les acteurs économiques dès cet été
c'est une réforme fondamentale quand
l'administration contrôle elle ne doit
pas tout de suite sanctionnés elle doit
accompagner expliqué pour corriger les
artisans les commerçants les pme le
vivent au quotidien ce sont eux les
principales victimes de la complexité
ensuite c'est supprimer le rsi pour les
commerçants et des artisans fondamentale
là aussi pour pouvoir croître et
embaucher et enfin c'est d'avoir un
droit du travail qui n'est pas
aujourd'hui comme aujourd'hui déterminé
par tous pour toutes les catégories tous
les secteurs dans une loi qui est devenu
trop rigide mais qui puisse renvoyer à
des accords majoritaires d'entreprise ou
des accords majoritaires de branches
qu'est ce que ça veut dire concrètement
avec une entreprise qui peut négocier un
accord majoritaire avec les
représentants des salariés qui permet de
s'organiser différemment pourra faire
face beaucoup mieux qu'elle ne le fait
aujourd'hui aux risques économiques à la
concurrence qu'elle subit c'est comme ça
d'ailleurs que les grandes entreprises
ont sauvé des emplois dans ce pays parce
que elles seules ont aujourd'hui la
possibilité de le faire donc du
pragmatisme pour les tpe les pme et pour
nos entreprises face justement à une des
cycles économiques qui sont beaucoup
plus court beaucoup plus heurté on en a
besoin avant qu'on ait tant de la
réponse de madame le pen c'est plus de
flexibilité également ses plus
déshérités pour les entreprises et ce
sont des sécurité pour les salariés les
ouvriers qui sont elles aussi nouvelle
c'est pour ça que à cette réforme
jacques hall une réforme de l'assurance
chômage de la formation professionnelle
pour qu'on protège vraiment les gens au
milieu de tous ces changements madame le
pen quelle est votre vision
hanches et du travail de ces nationale
messieurs le ministre de l'économie
dois je dire monsieur le conseiller
auprès de monsieur hollande c'est votre
vision donc du marché du travail madame
l'impétrant et xav été conseiller
économique de françois hollande depuis
deux ans ministre mais si vous avez la
recette pour diminution mal en quoi est
ce que vous n'avez pas ces tactiques en
finale pour lequel nous sommes candidats
restent dur facile en quoi est ce que
vous n'avez pas fait profiter monsieur
hollande de vos recettes et parce que si
vous n'avez pas de recettes parce que
vos résultats ont été en l'occurrence
extrêmement mauvais faut le dire en
matière de chômage alors pourquoi vous
vous présenter à la présidence de la
république si comme la seule vraie
question qu'on doit poser parce que vous
avez eu les mains libres pour mettre en
oeuvre cette politique et cette
politique elle a été catastrophique elle
a été catastrophique pourquoi pas ce que
vous avez fait la seule chose que vous
savez faire monsieur mâcon vous avez
aidé les grands groupes comme d'habitude
les cice vous l'avez accordé en fait en
priorité aux grands groupes les tpe pme
qui réclamait qu'on aille leur alléger
leurs difficultés leur donner de
l'oxygène vous avez fait comme s'il
n'existait pas parce que vous avez
refusé de supprimer la directive
détachement des travailleurs et
qu'aujourd'hui ce sont 300 à 500 mille
emplois qui en réalité ne sont pas
accessibles à nos compatriotes français
parce que ils sont
remplis par des travailleurs détachés
soit d'ailleurs qui fraude soit qui
fraudent pas parce que ceux qui fraudent
sont quasiment aussi nombreux en
l'occurrence que ceux qui fraudent pas
vous n'avez pas baisser les charges des
tpe pme vous n'avez pas mis en f2 délais
de paiement pour les tpe/pme pas de
guichet unique pas de simplification
administrative pas de patriotisme
économique ça ça vous aurait fuit parce
que vous êtes un e rep et est convaincu
donc tout ce qui vise à donner un
avantage dans la commande publique à nos
entreprises françaises vous êtes contre
parce qu'il faut se soumettre vous êtes
en fait la france qui se soumet qui se
soumet aux exigences de l'union
européenne à la concurrence
internationale déloyale les agriculteurs
ne vous ont pas vu les soutenir face à
cette concurrence internationale
déloyale les industriels ne vous ont pas
vu assis un certain nombre pardon de
encore une fois de grandes entreprises
vous ont vu ce sont celles que vous avez
fait acheter par des grands groupes
américains au détriment évidemment de
l'intérêt nationale c'est alstom c'est
technip il y en a eu toute une série
d'autres avec dans le cadre d'ailleurs
du conflit d'intérêts un peu
problématique avec l'ancienne banque
chez qui vous travaillez donc voyez vous
n'avez pas d'esprit national vous ne
pensez pas à l'intérêt supérieur de la
nation
vous défendez je vous le reprocheraient
toujours des intérêts privés je pense
que les français en ont pris conscience
le problème c'est que derrière il ya de
la casse il ya de la casse il ya de la
casse de votre politique à walpole il ya
les entreprises qui délocalisent et puis
ça ce n'est pas une anecdote monsieur
macron
ce sont des entreprises que vous avez
vendu
sfr par exemple à votre ami monsieur
draghi le patron de bfm
6000 emplois les autorités s'affairent
du saf est donc à peu près trois minutes
que madame le pen nous explique sa
stratégie pour lutter contre le chômage
en france je vous ai dis pas non mais il
n'y en a pas d'autres stratégies je vous
ai tout donné
vous n'avez pas fait madame le pen ce
qui est extraordinaire c'est que votre
stratégie mais c'est normal ça fait des
décennies que ça dure votre stratégie
c'est simplement de dire beaucoup de
mensonges et de dire tout ce qui ne va
pas dans le pays mais vous ne proposez
rien ce que si vous aviez suivi le film
des dernières années les charges ont
baissé le cx-7 une baisse de charge des
grandes que je propose non le séisme
c'est pour toutes les entreprises
savaient très bien que les tpe appels
venant n'ont pas profité
d'ailleurs même le pen c'est pour ça que
dans le projet que je porte je propose
de baisser de 6 points les charges des
tpe pme c'est pour ça que je propose de
baisser l'impôt sur les sociétés 25%
vous ne proposez rien toutes les
entreprises messieurs macro est conçu
pour les grosses vous êtes mais alors
que maire mais moi je moi je donne une
priorité totale aux tpe pme je vais vous
lire et l'emploi vous ne proposez rien
et vous êtes simplement vous faciliter
une fois de plus de lave et des grès
leur
vous êtes au spectateur vos amis dans
l'assignation cse et qui vous buvez déco
à l'art au tandem sont madame le pen les
français et les françaises il mérite
mieux que cela je vous assure il souffre
imerys oui il mérite d'abord la vérité
puisque les insinuations parce que si
vous étiez bien renseignés sur tous les
cas industriels que vous avez cités vous
seriez que c'est très différent je
n'étais pas ministre quand sfr a été
vendu sfr était la propriété d'un groupe
totalement privée qui était bonne pas
ministre non je n'étais pas me les avait
déjà commis ce mensonge devant 10
millions de personnes lors du débat que
nous avions eu et que monsieur savent
que vous ignoriez la poser cette
question évidemment vous étiez ministre
vous avez été alors manoeuvre sur
l'intégralité de ses domiciles et match
j'ai décidé que monsieur montebourg
refusé que sfr mais rendue à monsieur
draghi et le jour où monsieur montebourg
a été remplacé par vous monsieur macron
et bien immédiatement vous avez signé la
vente madame le pen à la réalité madame
le pen
sfr était la propriété d'un groupe privé
qui s'appelle vie 20 10 nous sommes dans
un état où la propriété privée respecter
c'est le groupe vivendi qui l'a vendue
ne dit pas de bêtise vous en dit
beaucoup saint-denis qu'une des bêtises
que vous avez proféré depuis tout à
l'heure mais surtout ça ne fait pas
avancer le pays très déçus car ils
voulaient pas la vendre mais personne ne
voulait la vendre sa propre simplement
quand vous avez un groupe privé qui est
détenue par des capitaux privés oui
chercher dans vos dossiers vous seriez
bien et je vais vous virer médias les
équipements et vous est ce que vous
allez être réduite et en messieurs plus
je connais je connais un peu chaude y
ait de mickey les deux en un sens et
j'ai pris la décision pour alstom vous
avez déjà dû monsieur dupont-aignan
c'est pas moi mais où parle d' alstom
janvier 2015 devant l'assemblée j'ai
pris la décision de permettre à general
electric de ramper
personnes madame le pen vous ne parlez
pas de lendemain le nord les d'alstom et
general electric
laissez-moi terminer une oppressante
rien meredith dans le chai montebourg
vous avez accordé alors qu'ils le
refusaient la vente de sfr et c'est la
réalité pourquoi vous l'assumez pas je
la subis nommé je laisse au fait le
mieux de dépecer des embiez prises et de
faire des fusions acquisitions ça vous
savez très bien que n ya aucun problème
vous êtes en train de lire une fiche qui
me correspond pas au dossier que vous
avez cités c'est triste pour vous parce
que ça montre votre impréparation à nos
concitoyens le dossier vendus contre les
intérêts de la clé c'est faux je n'étais
pas ministre pour sfr quant à general
electric alstom monsieur montebourg
s'est battu je me suis battu à ses côtés
pour que ça ne soit pas vendu on peut
rentrer si vous voulez dans l'intimité
du dossier vous n'allez pas tenir
longtemps parce que comme vous les
confondez les uns avec les autres filles
en un qui fait des téléphones et l'autre
ça n'a rien à voir il fut à la fois des
turbines et du matériel industriel
la même chose rendre vous voilà vous
savez tout ce sans problème c'est que
vous savez je défends mais pas aux
bénéfices moi je défends les intérêts ne
vous avez cité inca la lutte contre le
chômage elle suppose des réformes en
profondeur savez pas ce que vous pouvez
aller remuer les choses gomery
dérégulation des mandats
mais madame le pen ne veux pas faire un
débat sur le fond on a compris vos
débats grave mais je veux parler du
passé moi ce que je suis va parler de la
déréglementation fait ce dont nous avons
besoin aujourd'hui je les dis c'est de
la simplicité pour les tpe les tpe pme
c'est ce que je propose on a besoin
d'avoir beaucoup plus de pragmatisme et
on a besoin d'avoir une politique en
faveur de l'investissement privé et
public mais macron c'est indispensable
pour lutter contre le chômage il n'y a
pas de fatalité vous ne proposez rien
pour lutter contre le chômage rien je
vous donne l'occasion aux pauses et
d'aller chercher de manière on arrive le
13 approximatif dans des dossiers que
vous ne connaissez sur écran des cas
mais moi je propose de créer de l'emploi
pour les indépendants les tpe pme les
entreprises et d'accompagner un média et
le grand groupe propose justement de
faire des propositions maintenant sur un
sujet qui intéresse beaucoup les
français aussi c'est la durée du travail
il semble qu'aucun d'entre vous dans son
programme ne propose de revenir sur la
durée légale du travail 35 heures marine
le pen les 35 heures vous convient donc
aujourd'hui moi je veux que les
négociations aient lieu par branche
monsieur macro lui veut que les enfants
les négociations aient lieu par
entreprise et dj clairement je ne
crierai side je dirai ce que j'ai
apprécié faisons mais pas ses fratricide
parce qu'il est évident que la
négociation par entreprise s'est jeté
les entreprises les unes contre les
autres vous allez créer les conditions
d'une concurrence internationale
déloyale alors que déjà une subissent
une concurrence internationale déloyale
vous savez très bien que dans les
branches il y aura les grosses
entreprises qui pourront évidemment aux
modules et ce dans le travail et que les
petites ne pourrons pas et donc elles
seront amenées à disparaître mais c'est
aussi ça un petit peu votre projet les
gros mangent les petits voilà c'est un
peu la loi du plus fort en réalité bon
eh bien moi je suis totalement opposé à
ça je pense que si négociations il y à
elle doit se faire par branche et
surtout pas par entreprise je note
d'ailleurs que monsieur macron faire une
loi comrie puissance 10 1 par ordonnance
vous l'avez dit on ne sait pas trop ce
qu'il ya dedans je suppose qu'il y aura
la disparition j'ai pas du cdi enfin
toute la feuille de route qui est celle
de l'union européenne que vous suivez
dont vous cochez les cases avec beaucoup
de discipline il faut lui dire mais
c'est pas qu'on vous êtes dit ce matin n
2 d'être disciplinés à l'égard de
l'union européenne oui je le lis
reviendra nous redire notre siècle ce
sont les 35 binamé d'accord mais cette
dérégulation totale
cette case du droit du travail ça va
être évidemment une politique de
précarisation ça ne va pas créer de
l'emploi et donc à créer des chômeurs
supplémentaires or tant qu'on ne
changera pas le modèle économique qui a
été défendu par le système monsieur
mâcon qui est derrière vous avec tous
les ministres socialistes là que vous
avez reçue qui vous soutiennent le forum
sur le fond mais mme royal mais mme
taubira monsieur cazeneuve et avec le
nord nous apprend bien votre réponse sur
les 35 heures c'est très bien eh bien tu
cela ils ont été dans la maison rideaux
non mais je préfère vous essayé mais
c'est un classe non mais vous aviez vous
devrez faire oublier maintenant on va
essayer de faire oublier que vous avez
participé à un gouvernement qui a mis en
oeuvre la loi elle comme rick a été une
fois encore une fois de précarisation du
travail qui n'a pas créé un emploi qui a
créé un chômage qui est encore plus
important depuis que vous êtes partis du
gouvernement que quand vous y est entré
mais ça je vois que vous refusé d'en
assumer la responsabilité de thomas g
implicite non mais je note que vous
refusez encore une fois cette
responsabilité donc les mesures que vous
préconisez aujourd'hui c'est bon les a
vus si vous nous dit on va faire ça
empire et bien moi je dis qu'il faut
évidemment radicalement tourné le dos à
cette politique là et il faut enfin
faire une politique de protection encore
une fois des emplois et de développement
des tpe pme parce que ce sont elles qui
créent l'emploi dans notre pays et le
maquereau en votre tour donc vous ne
revenez pas vous non plus sur la durée
légale de tron est un nom qui est
extraordinaire c'est qu'on aurait dû ne
répondait en fait jamais aux questions
vous parlez toujours du passé et des
autres mais c'est très bien les français
comprendront vous n'avez rien à proposer
c'est formidable moi je vous écoute vous
parlez de vous écouter les besoins de
tous deux vous entendrez jeudi matin
j'ai répondu oh que je suis moi
simplement en train de répondre
précisément parce que c'est ce qui
m'intéresse c'est l'avis de notre pays
les tpe pme qu'est ce qu'elle demande
vous avez été voir les chefs
d'entreprise ils veulent quoi plus de
visibilité ils veulent pouvoir qu'il
soit tpe pme entreprises de taille
intermédiaire c'est pas du tout les
grands groupes qui le demandent les
grands groupes qui gèrent très bien la
complexité cris s'en fiche complètement
mais toutes ces entreprises de
l'entreprise d'un salarié jusqu'à 500
elles veulent quoi elles veulent plus
d'adaptation à leur réalité économique
une entreprise qui est dans le btp qui a
deux salariés elle n'a pas le même
quotidien qu'une startups du numérique
ou qu'une entreprise qui a 500 salariés
dans l'automobile ce n'est pas la même
réalité et donc il faut leur laisser la
possibilité de négocier pour certaines
un accord majoritaire d'entreprise les
grands groupes seul le peuvent
aujourd'hui dans certaines circonstances
et ont sauvé des emplois les chantiers
de l'atlantique à saint nazaire ils ont
sauvé des emplois en négociant un accord
d'entreprise qui a permis le chômage
partiel est due aux italiens j'essaie de
dire des grande bêtise à part dont vous
les avez vendu en alliage les i madame
le pen je sais je n'ai rien vendu pour
ce qui est des chantiers de l'atlantique
ils ont failli périr il ya deux ans ils
ont pu négocier un accord d'entreprise
que les syndicats ont courageusement
signé il ya eu du chômage partiel aucun
licenciement ils sont repartis dans un
carnet de commandes de 10 ans et ils ont
été vendus aux italiens non ils n'ont
pas été vendus comme vous le dites à qui
que ce soit et ce n'est pas votre
serviteur puisque j'étais à ce moment là
dans la campagne présidentielle comme
vous donc vous pouvez m'insulter tous
les péchés des 30 dernières années je
suis dans la vie politique depuis moins
longtemps que vous faites quand même
fait un temps cette transaction
libération non madame rita sur la table
il vous a fait un gros problème avec les
dossiers industriels voulait travailler
pas mal j'ai un certain temps max nash
était surtout votre coude non madame
madame le pen pour ma part j'ai signé
des contrats pour que des bateaux soient
construits sur ses chantiers mais je
vous dis simplement que ils ont pu
signer ces accords qui donnait la
flexibilité qui permettait justement
garder l'emploi c'est ce que je veux
pour les autres entreprises c'est ce que
les chefs d'entreprise demande et je
suis aussi favorable à ce que en
particulier pour les plus petites îles
et y ait des accords de branche parce
que une entreprise d'un deux salariés
elle ne négocie pas elle ne négocie pas
des accords d'entreprise parce que bien
souvent il n'y a pas de syndicat et donc
pour les artisans les commerçants les
toutes petites entreprises qui nous
écoutent et bien ce au niveau de la
branche qu'on pourra négocier justement
les souplesses plus adapté que dans la
loi qui permettront d'embaucher plus
facilement notre économie elle en a
besoin elle en a besoin d'une grosse et
des petites entreprises oui mais vous
êtes survient après que des petites
entreprises j'ai compris que vous étiez
aussi favorable pour la branche mais
précisément pour éviter que les plus
grosses ne perturbe le jeu il faut leur
laisser signé des accords aussi de leur
côté voilà c'est exactement ce qui
permettra une vitalité à notre économie
c'est ce qui évitera de détruire de
l'emploi dès qu'on a une récession comme
on l'a connu en 2009 partait du principe
que c'est le code du travail qui crée en
réalité du chômage je parle là c'est une
vision quand même qui est assez
particulière moi je pars du principe et
c'est encore une fois ce que disent les
tpe pme que je rencontre monsieur vous
savez beaucoup plus que vous car encore
une fois
les parties bien souvent des droits et
faire des scènes fixes et salariés de
poule on ne soyez pas méprisant une fois
de plus avec les salariés mais moi j'ai
du temps après ils m'ont très bien
accueilli car ils savent que le projet
qui est le mien les défends parce qu'ils
savent ce qui les tue c'est la politique
que vous menez c'est la politique de
concurrence encore une fois déloyal
c'est la politique qui fait que l'état
stratège
n'intervient pas et laisse encore une
fois les gros manger les petits ils
laissent les intéristes partir chercher
mais le des travailleurs bien cool des
travailleurs à bas coût lors avec nous
et ça a été le cas mais je leur propose
de taxer les entreprises qui
délocalisent elles ne délocalisent rond
plus monsieur macron si elles n'ont pas
de bénéfices si elles n'ont pas de
bénéfice à aller dans un pays où les
salaires sont très bas si elles sont
taxées lorsqu'elle réimportent leurs
produits alors elles ne partiront plus
car elles n'ont pas d'intérêt financier
à le faire ça c'est la première chose
deuxièmement je veux mettre en place un
fonds souverain un fond souvent qui
permettent d'intervenir par exemple dans
un dossier comme vivarte qui est en
train d'être dépassé par des fonds
vautours
et bien moi je crois que l'état doit
intervenir confié un fonds souverain des
chefs d'entreprise et avoir en même
temps les deux qualités celles de l'état
qu'est la durée et celles du privé qui
est l'efficacité et en réclamant à des
entreprises qui sont viables des
rendements qu'ils sont
raisonnable quand vous vous considérez
encore une fois que la loi du plus fort
doit s'appliquer que il est normal que
des entreprises se délaissent les unes
des autres c'est ce que vous avez
organisé lorsque vous étiez à la tête de
la banque n'aura pas d'âme le pen vous
savez j'ai deux roues
ça existe ça existe il ya quelque chose
qui s'appelle l' agence des
participations de l'état où l'état peut
investir dans une entreprise il est
décidé par exemple quand peugeot était
menacé l'état a investi est montée au
capital pour sauver l'entreprise et il
ya je leur propose vous dit que c'était
quelque chose n'ont jamais rien je peux
accepter c'est intéressant de la russie
ont signé ce cas là c'est un fonds
souverain que je confierai mois à des
chefs d'entreprise et des familles à la
banque publie en avez-vous vraiment
dense avait été créé si messieurs dames
le pen et je veux c'est un art on
sauvera de quoi bon mais n'importe quoi
mais ce n'est pas vrai le fonds
ne jouais pas ne joue pas
malheureusement très vous cherchez à
jouer avec moi l'élève et aux
professeurs mais en ce qui concerne ce
n'est pas particulièrement mon truc je
me dis moi non plus avait 7 ans le pays
mérite mieux parce que dans le cadre et
le pool ce que vous proposez sais rien
vous proposez d'abord vous ne respectez
pas les vous ne respectez pas non je
répondrais sur le frein à ce sujet parce
que moi j'ai entendu la colère moi j'ai
passé des heures avec eux vous vous les
respectez pas vous êtes passé un quart
d'heure sur le paris j'aime passer ma
quand vous n'êtes pas rentrer vous
n'êtes même pas rentré de l'autre côté
des barrières de l'entreprise là vous
n'avez pas des journalistes moi je suis
rentré pour aller dans les journalistes
des journalistes qu elle est au
contraire une caméra d'aller au contact
mois des salariés parce que c'est ça
respecter les gens ça là et pendant que
vous faisiez vous votre numéro avec les
caméras moi j'étais avec les
représentants des salariés parce que je
les respecte et vous savez quoi ils ont
bien compris que vous leur proposez rien
sont bien compris vous leur proposez
vous aux le soir même un cran mais oui
parce qu'il a l'air et moi je prends
encore bingo les hors jeu prend
toute la campagne mais j'ai parlé de
rien j'ai mis avec leur colère madame le
pen et le soir vous faites un communiqué
en proposant quoi la nationalisation de
whirlpool la mise sous protection
l'essai a le temps de travail reprend
les côtes certains ont essayé que vous
condamnez ils ont eu des problèmes c'est
exactement l'erreur qu'a fait monsieur
hollande apec florange et vous vous êtes
allé les voir en leur disant tu as
écouté la mondialisation
pour la reprise du site un des tous
meilleurs que formation je leur ai dit
je vais me battre pour la reprise du
site industriel parce que ça c'est un
vrai combat je vais me battre pour que
vous ayez des supra légale pour des
queues dans l'anecdote que j'aime ça que
j'ai je sur ce suivi le monsieur macron
puis vous dire vous rendez suis
infiniment plus crédible que vous parce
que je ne me nourris pas cette
insignifiance des salariés devient on
attendait on va avancer mon doit avancer
nos concitoyens se battre et savez j'ai
eu des victoires j'ai eu des échecs mais
je me suis toujours battue et des
victoires pour protéger de l'exemple
wade s'était vu refuser d emploi d entre
eux ce cv qui s'achève les autres
français et qui dégraisse arc
international
on l'a ya des tas d'entreprises vont et
viennent nous écouter deux minutes et il
leur arrive samedi au trinquet jamais
jamais je n'ai fait ce que vous avez
fait l'autre jour c'est à dire aller
profiter allez profiter de la détresse
des gens ça on aura l'occasion de
revenir
c'est un jamais je tente de me planquer
dans une salle de
mais reste sur sa faim dit qu il fallait
me plaise ou non
on a compris je l'avais au milieu d'eux
et moi aussi je n'ai pas été dans son
nom mais au
rendez vous et les mines amont prix est
la première à passer trois heures selon
des médias les
salariés attendent et c'est inaudible
alors on va continuer y aura d'autres
d'autre occasion d'aborder les problèmes
qui se posent les français comme vous
dites alors on va aborder le sujet des
impôts et du pouvoir d'achat alors il ya
beaucoup de français qui expriment une
sorte de ras-le-bol fiscale à savoir mm
elles vont cros macron ce que vous
proposez ce que vous comprenez cette
espèce d'impression de ras-le-bol voilà
c'est clair parce que je propose c'est
de faire des économies pour pouvoir
baisser les impôts des entreprises et
des ménages parce que il faut d'abord
être clair si on ne fait pas d'économies
ça ne sert à rien de promettre aux gens
qu'on va baisser les impôts ça c'est une
promesse qui ne tient pas j'ai bien que
celle que vous faites mais les gens ne
sont pas bêtes donc l'état est
aujourd'hui en déficit ce qui n'est pas
bon pour nous l'état et l'ensemble des
collectivités publiques moi je propose
de faire sur le quinquennat de 60
milliards d'économies pour pouvoir
baisser notre déficit de 15 milliards
est baissé de 10 milliards les impôts et
les charges des entreprises
la baisse des charges on a dit tout à
l'heure jusqu à 2 smic et demie 6 points
de charge en moins des points de charge
en moins au niveau du smic pour les
entreprises et une baisse de l'impôt sur
les sociétés de 33,3 à 25 pour ça et du
côté de nos concitoyens des ménages je
propose de supprimer la taxe
d'habitation pour 80 % de nos
concitoyens ça correspond à 10 milliards
d'euros voilà donc je baisse les impôts
des entreprises pour 10 milliards les
impôts de nos concitoyens pour 10
milliards et je fais 60 milliards
d'économies voilà le projet budgétaire
et fiscale qui est le mien si la
croissance se porte mieux que ce que
j'ai prévu parce que je suis très
prudent sur les années à venir je ne
fais jamais dépassé dans les hypothèses
qui sont les miennes la croissance de
1,8 pour cent j'espère qu'on pourra
aller plus loin alors j'aurai
affecterait ce qu'on gagnera sur la
baisse de l'impôt sur le revenu et donc
sur les ménages madame le pen vos
propositions en matière de pouvoir
d'achat est ce que le ras-le-bol fiscale
c'est quelque chose que vous avez
ressenti sur le terrain l'appareil
aucune responsabilité je n'ai jamais été
une proposition à la ministre madame le
pen vous n'avez pas participé aux grands
choix économiques alors si si si vous
considérez comme si vous avez un
gouvernement qui a fait 35 milliards de
taxes et d'impôts supplémentaires au
gouvernement nommé alors je vous le
caviar de taxes et d'impôts
supplémentaires pendant le quinquennat
mais c'est pas vous ok j'étais en charge
de 112 voulait baisser la taxe
d'habitation ce qui moi me va bien pour
les petits taxe d'habitation mais en
revanche donc similaire c'est ça mais en
revanche vous voulez augmenter la csg de
1,75 point 20 milliards de plus pour les
travailleurs pour les retraités alors
nous devons voir peser sur eux
d'ailleurs monsieur pisani ferry qui est
un de vos conseillers l'a dit clairement
60 % des retraités vont effectivement
devoir payer plus de ram le pen c'est
normal
et je choque l'armée car je voudrais te
dire je regardais valérie le pen l'a
d'emmanuel macro sur la csg des
retraités non oui mais c'est faux
puisque qu'est-ce que je fais là car je
oui d'accord d'accord je baisse d'un peu
plus de 3 points les charges salariales
de toutes celles et ceux qui travaillent
pourquoi parce que aujourd'hui quand
vous avez votre feuille de paye vous
touchez votre salaire brut et vous avez
ensuite vos cotisations salariales sur
la maladie sur le chômage je les
supprime ça fait un peu plus de 3 points
de charges salariales pourquoi parce que
je veux aller au bout de ce système où
l'assurance chômage doit être universel
parce que je veux que les artisans que
les commerçants que les agriculteurs
puissent toucher le chômage ils ne l'ont
pas aujourd'hui ça n'est pas juste et
donc je finance le chômage par l'impôt
donc je supprime pour tous les
travailleurs leurs cotisations sociales
salariales et je le remplace par 1,7
point de csg qu'est ce que cela veut
dire ça veut dire que toutes les
personnes qui travaillent artisans
indépendants agriculteurs entrepreneurs
commerçants fonctionnaires salariés ils
auront je vais finir un gain de pouvoir
d'achat ils gagneront plus parce que
cette hausse de csg elle est inférieure
à la baisse de charge ils gagneront tous
du pouvoir d'achat les 40 sans de
retraités les plus modestes qui ont un
taux réduit de csg ne seront pas
affectés par cette mesure ils n'auront
rien et les 60 % de retraités qui ont le
taux normal or on a eu une augmentation
de 1,7 point de csg et bien les plus
aisés des plus aisés je leur demanderai
cet effort pour avoir un système plus
intelligent pour leurs enfants et leurs
petits-enfants parce qu'à pas de
finances magique contrairement à ce que
vous dites même à crosby et à touba de
quatre minutes d'avancé de la danse arts
compte pour tous les autres mais c'est
très important donc je prends ces quatre
minutes parce que je veux trouver mais
elle mérite le pen à savoir les autres
retraités et bien cette eau salée
compensé par la suppression de la taxe
d'habitation pour eux et donc paris le
priol et son lac david jauzion
vient de leur accorder de la main droite
est en réalité que vous reprenez le
maglev par l'impôt non mais comme vous
êtes socialiste vous allez nous dire
c'est pas ça coûte rien c'est l'état qui
paye non je ne vous dis juste que mon
passage se rétablit la vérité sont vos
propositions rapidement gagnent en
pouvoir d'achat avec cette mesure alors
ça fait plus effet des retraités alors
moi j'ai évidemment et monsieur mac on
me le reproche souvent d'ailleurs
effectivement des mesures extrêmement
importante pour le pouvoir d'achat pour
rendre l'argent aux français et
notamment qui passe par la baisse de 10%
des trois premières tranches de l'impôt
sur le revenu qui passe par le
rétablissement de la demi part des veufs
et veuves que les socialistes ont quand
même maintenu ce qui était assez ignoble
je trouve parce que ils auraient pu
faire un effort sur ce sujet là par la
défiscalisation des heures
supplémentaires pour rendre du pouvoir
d'achat ce qui travaillent par des
mesures claires de primes de pouvoir
d'achat pour les salaires et les
retraites de moins de 1500 euros par
mois que je fais financé par une
contribution sociale à l'importation et
non pas par l'impôt monsieur macron et
puis il ne baisse du prix du gaz et de
l'électricité de 5 % parce
qu'aujourd'hui il ya eu des hauts
successifs qui pèsent considérablement
sur le budget des familles je revalorise
les petites retraites parce que vous
allez taper sur les retraités
savez ils sont dans une situation pour
beaucoup d'entre eux qui sont absolument
dramatiques ils n'arrivent plus à
boucler les fins de mois et il continue
à voir toujours tomber sur eux d demande
des efforts et des sacrifices
supplémentaires vous avez indiqué que
l'apl on ne va pas vous suit on va pas
continuer indéfiniment à financer 20
millions de ménages par des appels en
nourrissant l'inflation immobilière et
bien si vous retirez les aides au
logement il ya toute une série dames le
foyer que vous ne pourrez plus qu'ils ne
pourront plus se loger et bien moi je
veux que notamment pour les jeunes les
moins de 27 ans puissent voir leur aide
au logement augmenté de 25% et puis j'ai
pensé aux familles parce que vous y
pensez pas beaucoup aux familles je vais
penser aux familles par le
rétablissement du quotient familial
puisqu'il a été baissée sont les
socialistes le gouvernement qu'elle vous
avez participé qui est la bessée et puis
retourne revenir à l'universalité des
allocations familiales pour permettre
aux familles à nouveau qui ont vu peser
sur elle tout l'effort que le
gouvernement auquel vous avez participé
monsieur le ministre est bien à fait
peser sur leur budget soit quelques
stars niveau de revenus et les familles
oui oui je suis luxé le principe de
l'universalité
donc voyez moi je suis la candidate du
pouvoir d'achat vous monsieur macron
vous êtes le candidat du pouvoir
d'acheter d'acheter la france de la
dépecer c'est ce que dans votre société
ben oui c'est important quand même de
savoir quelle est la philosophie de
votre projet dans votre site et tout est
à vendre et tout est à acheter voilà les
hommes sont à vendre et acheter les
ventres sont à vendre et acheter comme
d'ailleurs monsieur bergé qui est un de
vos soutiens nous l'a expliqué vous ne
voyez les rapports humains que par
rapport à ce que ça rapporte par rapport
au dividende que on peut en tirer ça
n'est pas du tout ma vision moi je pense
que le don je pense que la la la les
efforts qui sont faits par exemple
bénévoles par les bénévoles dans les
associations les aidants 8 millions
auxquels je vais me tourner pour leur
offrir un trimestre supplémentaire tous
les cinq trimestres parce que s'il
n'était pas là les 8 millions d'aidants
eh bien nous ne pourrions pas faire face
au coût que cela représenterait tout ce
monde associatif bénévole auquel on
pense pas et qui est un des éléments de
notre identité française mouillé dans
dans ma vision à moi moi je raconte tout
n'est pas à vendre et tout n'est pas
acheter tout ne fait pas l'objet d'un
d'un poids financier d'une mesure
financière de statistiques financières
la france c'est bien autre chose que ce
mais vous avez raison la france c'est
bien autre chose c'est une civilisation
ouverte avec des principes généreux
tools inverse de ce que vous portez ce
n'est pas la xénophobie ça n'est pas
votre vision des familles celle encore
que votre père appelait ya quelques
jours de manière indigne ou celle que
vous avez constamment me met à l'eau
parlement européen comme dans les
régions que vous avez cherché à diriger
en sus prix en proposant de supprimer
les crédits au planning familial etc
parlez pas trop de la famille en ce qui
vous concerne vous avez une vision de la
famille qui n'a jamais été la famille
française mais moi j'ai une question à
vous poser comment vous financer tout ça
madame le pen a mais je vais vous
trouvez des économique alors où tu te
régales et l'union européenne rien aux
rebelles le fun 9 milliards d'euros par
an soyez moins 10 ans et non six
milliards mais vous oubliez les droits
de douane gênerait mais non c'est cissé
6 milliards ont brillé les droits 5
apporte alors allez-y on a en faisant
que vous êtes en fait moins technique
parce que vous voulez bien l'esprit de
vos propositions
faudra l'aborder dans le formulaire du
midan sion mais on sent les uns comme
adam le permettront d'atteindre une
liste à la prévert pour montrer sa
générosité région mais nous allons me da
ble 7 entre 100 m à 50 milliards de
dépassement générosité monsieur macro et
non messieurs et dames l'argent leur
argent aux français c'est leur argent
vous le pousse à développer leur argent
le prenait à n'est pas vous qui le crée
cet argent rené n est pas le
gouvernement auquel vous avez participé
madame le pen c'est leur argent on leur
rang et c'est tout à fait légitime qui
le même accro et marina bay le lac aux
élections mais l'union et des 350
milliards de milliards par an alors
allez l'immigration à une coup un coup
absolument spectaculaire je n'ai
conservé que 15 milliards d'économies
par an j'ai été extrêmement raisonnable
voyez dans mes calculs il y à la fraude
sociale contre lesquelles vous n'avez
pas lutter bien sûr ça de vous arrêter
du jour au lendemain mais du jour au
lendemain présidente les gens vont
arrêter de venir il n'y aura plus de
fraude sociale plus de fraude fiscale
tout va bien se passer du jour au
lendemain comme ça formidable mais c'est
formidable les seuils non moi j'ai pas
envie de me montrer j'ai pas envie je
suis mieux de faire arrêter comme ça
c'est quoi j'ai pas envie d'essayer les
français n'ont plus du tout envie
d'essayer avec v les français ne parlait
pas alors planant je parlais pas à leur
place mais ils ont pas envie tout ça
avait plutôt la position aujourd'hui du
candidat par défaut choisi par dieu par
toute une série de gens alors vous
devriez faire preuve d'un peu moins
d'arrogance mais la belle élection vous
dis juste que moi je prends les
françaises et les français pour des
adultes je ne leur ment pas je ne leur
ment pas vous embêter les aviez vous
avez tenté de les orienter lisais
beaucoup moins derrière manque en
permanence là vous faites une liste à la
prévert vous ne la finance est pas qui
plus est le jour où vous obtiendrez vous
6 vous prétendez 9 milliards d'euros par
an à l'union européenne mais doit
d'abord payer tout ce qu'on doit l'union
européenne regarder ce que fait la
grande bretagne avec le break si tu es
là à payer entre si oui mais elle a payé
entre 60 et 90 euros mais elle a dès le
début a payé entre 60 et 80 milliards
d'euros née début voilà aussi donc c'est
de l'argent qui est ça coûte et ensuite
il y as mais on y viendra avec grand
plaisir sur l'euro et aux conséquences
et le prevenar projet mais vous ne
financer pas ce que vous promettez donc
je veux juste que nos concitoyens par
rapport à la liste que vous avez fait
parce que moi les aidant nos
associations je les soutiendrai je les
soutiendrai mois et où vos d'hivernage
et j'ai eu la courtoisie de rappeler
comment je finançais mais baisse d'un
point c'est la mesure que je fais sur la
csg c'est pour financer des baisses de
charges salariales vous ce sont des
cadeaux mais quelqu'un va payer je veux
que nos concitoyens la vie prennent les
cas quelqu'un va payer vous proposer des
augmentations dead écho des baisses
d'impôts que vous ne financeraient
d'idées cadeaux je dis madame le pen que
votre projet est un projet caché donc
rendre l'argent méandres la veille les
français aux france est un cadeau madame
le pen voulait pour vous préférez le dos
n'est acquis mais je le donne à personne
ozap le mans que quand vous baissez des
amis des puissances financier baisse des
impôts si vous n'avez pas baisser des
dépenses en face tous nos concitoyens
qui nous écoutent peuvent le comprend
baisse des dépenses auxquelles vous ne
voulez pas touché mais je ne me fais
aucune dépense madame le pen n'arrive
même pas vrai s'il vous plaît nous
reviendrons tout à l'heure que vous
allez soit creusé le déficit et dépendre
des marchés financiers alors soit
augmenter les impôts durant votre
quinquennat mais vous ne le dites pas
soit augmenter la dette et à ce moment
là ce sont nos enfants qui paieront je
ne veux aucune de ces solutions aucune
c'est tout l'art à vous en a fait 3 ce
matin hier je crois de dieu on va
revenir tout à l'heure on viendra serait
ce n'est pas le cas c'est d'assumer son
bilan moi j'assume totalement mon bilan
le problème c'est que vous n'arrivez
grèce reviendra industriel provence
tout à l'heure je voudrais que je porte
le fardeau des 20 dernières années ont
nourri sa montée en gamme et la
prospérité j'avais été conseiller
ministre salaires efira mais même pas ce
que je vais commencer par faire ça
madame le 9 hrs de vérité et d'honnêteté
que d'assumer auprès des français
jettent les résultats qui ont été les
leurs sur tout mon mandat de mini art
dubaï avant goût sur l'a25 est invité à
marine ne pas les responsabilités des
obus du débat comme intervient en
simplement sur le chiffre a imputé des
choses se sont faites vous-même [ __ ] et
des choses qui étaient avant que je sois
ministre et surtout farid beaucoup de
buts maintenant on va voir l'avenir
attendait un rapport à la vérité alors
pas le bon on va fait le propre de tout
et de tous les extrêmes et donc c'est
votre mana mais là trop vous en veux pas
imposer très en avance à la ont été
insultés votre mii je ne vous insulte
traversèrent si les dames le prenne pour
vous savez depuis tout à l'heure si
quelqu'un insulte et l'autre c'est
plutôt vous allez me semble pas
quand la madame le pen vous dites que je
ne respecte pas le corps des femmes en
faisant un raccourci indigne avec
monsieur bergé avec la gpa oui je n'ai
j'ai toujours été très clair sur la
gestation pour autrui on n'était pas
franchement l'armée parce que madame le
pen à mes yeux c'est juste mon chrono
téléspectateurs apprennent c'est un
mensonge j'ai toujours dit que j'étais
contre les gpéens voilà oui mais vous
êtes ballon d'or vous êtes d'accord pour
que les gpa qui ont lieu à l'étranger en
réalité on les emploie green sur le
territoire national c'est à dire que
vous êtes en train de créer des filières
de gpa à l'étranger et non seulement
aussi ignoble sur le plan à l'art de la
commercialisation du corps humain mais
c'est en plus particulièrement cynique
et hypocrite totalement contre la gpa
gelé dire dis simplement quand vous avez
un enfant sur le territoire français
vous préférez le laisser sans droits ça
correspond à votre vision de l'humanité
mais ça n'est pas la mienne moi je crois
d'un ingénieur alors on y va on a 100 et
dans des principes on avance marine le
pen on avancerait ont pris de la
commercialisation des garmin amazon de
scène je suis contre la corée alors on
nouvel esclavage moderne entre le fait
qu'un enfant qui n'a rien demandé à
personne et qui n'est à l'autre bout du
monde sur 100 et 300 à la taille il peut
très bien bénéficier d'une tutelle
monsieur max non mais vous la
reconnaissez assuré avec vous il aura la
tutelle et puis pourra mourir dans la
rue parce qu'il aura plus les murs alors
allons-y
avec son président oui vous avez raison
et cbr sérieux et votre projet n'en a
pas vraiment un peu de ça les apparences
depuis le début revenons-en à ce sujet
qui intéresse nous tous nous
téléspectateurs à savoir les protections
sociales je voudrais savoir quels sont
les progrès que vous proposer aux
français en matière de remboursement par
la sécurité sociale
c'est à vous vous avez à léger temps de
retard et après ce sera monsieur macron
de faire c'est propose d'abord je veux
sauver système de protection sociale
parce que la réalité c'est que
aujourd'hui ce système de protection
sociale il est mis en danger vous avez
bien vu que l'objectif c'est d'essayer
de le démanteler par un bon ou par un
autre on parle de financement d'ailleurs
monsieur macron vous avez fait toute une
série las de proposition de
remboursement de l'optique etc mais vous
avez vous êtes restés extrêmement floue
merci que c'est quoi les verts les
montures à quel niveau bon on n'en sera
pas plus avant probablement l'élection
mais ce qui est sûr c'est qu'il ya là
encore beaucoup d'économies à faire sans
baisser les prestations qui sont
accordés et notamment par des progrès et
l'utilisation des progrès numérique par
exemple avec la vente à l'unité des
médicaments tout cela n'est pas mis en
place et ça pourrait être mis en place
de manière extrêmement simple et puis au
delà de la protection sociale il ya
l'offre de soins et l'offre de soins on
se retrouve confronté à la difficulté de
la désertification
c'est à dire que dans beaucoup de nos
campagnes eh bien il faut aller à
parfois 50 60 km pour réussir à trouver
peut-être pas un généraliste mais au
moins spécialistes et parfois quatre
mois ou six mois pour obtenir un rendez
vous donc là il y a encore une fois des
mesures qui sont des mesures claires à
mettre en oeuvre d'abord augmenter le
numerus clausus que vous n'avez pas
touché 1 lorsque vous étiez aux
responsabilités plus aujourd'hui nous
n'avons pas assez de médecins nous
sommes obligés d'aller chercher des
médecins à l'étranger en privant
d'ailleurs bien souvent les pays de
cette offre de soins que nous allons
chercher chez eux il faut mettre en
place d'un stage d'internât de six mois
dans des territoires qui sont sous
denses en matière de santé il faut
proposer des baisses de fiscalité pour
les médecins qui sont à la retraite pour
leur suggérer de rester pendant un
certain nombre de mois un certain nombre
d'années ce deux choses un consensus de
gens savaient parler tout à l'air des
prothèses auditives des prothèses
dentaires de l'optique est ce que dans
votre programme il ya des plus par
rapport à ce qu'on a actuellement nous
feront surtout en sorte que les
médicaments baisse que le coût des
médicaments baisse car si on obtient la
baisse du coût des médicaments et bien
alors on ne remboursera plus et alors on
pourra se servir de ces fonds pour
pouvoir rembourser des choses qui
aujourd'hui reste à la charge de nos
compatriotes et il ya un bras de fer à
faire avec les laboratoires quand je les
dis on m'a expliqué que ce n'était pas
possible et puis j'ai vu que
dernièrement quand même il avait été
obtenu qu'un médicament et abc un
médicament qui était terriblement cher à
baisser je crois de près d'un tiers ou
de la moitié donc vous imaginez c'est
est considérable voilà il faut un moment
donné la volonté politique or cette
volonté politique elles n'existent plus
parce qu on se soumet aux grands
laboratoires parce qu on se soumet aux
grandes puissances financières et puis
parce qu'il ya derrière eux des gens qui
ont des intérêts privés vous en avez
dans votre équipe quelqu'un qui a été ré
privé un qui travaille chez servier a
payé et à aubin oui parce qu'il était
étonné on avait vu dans le programme de
monsieur macron il y avait le
remboursement particulièrement de
l'hypertension s'est dit mais pourquoi
particulièrement l'hypertension va plus
quand on a appris que son conseiller
santé en réalité était un des plus gros
lobbyiste de servier et que servier
c'est précisément le grand laboratoire
dont le domaine de prédilection elle
lutte contre l'hypertension alors pour
répondre à la mauvaise hervé vous êtes
jeunes à égalité maintenant donc je suis
partagé une partie des recommandations
et d'ailleurs c'est dans mon projet mais
sur les médicaments j'ai une mauvaise
nouvelle
80 % des médicaments sont faits à
l'étranger comme vous taxer les
importations
on va augmenter le prix pas de chance
pour toutes celles et ceux qui nous
écoutent avec madame le pen on a une
taxe on n'a pas bien compris trois dit
ça dépend de vos porte parole enfin on
va taxer les importations avec vous donc
on va plus concret non mais dont on a
abandonné l'idée mais j'avais semé la
mort at war qui se développe en france
en ac on en à madame le pen on en a
alors il faut les booster et il faut les
booster 80% mais on va pas du jour au
lendemain faire 80 % des médicaments
qu'on apporte sa marche pas comme ça
dans la vraie vie ça marche pas comme ça
sur les plateaux de télévision peut-être
mais pas dans la vraie vie donc pendant
les années qui viennent si vous êtes
d'élus et bien tous les médicaments
augmenteront tout cas 80 % tous ceux qui
sont importés je dis ça pour montrer
l'incohérence de ce que vous proposez
aux français ensuite le vrai problème en
effet mais ce qui l'est c'est tout à
fait vrai vous pourrez vérifier vous
devez être dans vos dossiers alors sur
le reste le l'un des vrais problèmes ce
sont nos déserts médicaux ça c'est tout
à fait juste 30 % des départements on a
plus de continuité des soins et donc on
doit la investir dans ces maisons
pluridisciplinaires de santé dans une
meilleure organisation entre la médecine
publique et la médecine privée pour
faciliter ce qu'on appelle le parcours
du patient pour permettre de plus
facilement à les sortir de l'hôpital dès
que c'est possible pour aller vers des
maisons de soins plus facilement accéder
à des spécialistes wade médecins sur le
territoire pour ne pas que tout le monde
aille aux urgences et parfois une demi
heure aux trois quarts d'heure de
voiture je pense d'ailleurs en
particulier à nos territoires
d'outre-mer où là il y a un besoin
criant de santé la guyane en en
particulier mais la plupart quasi tous
les territoires ultramarins ont ce
problème d'une offre de santé et de
spécialistes
et aujourd'hui on dépense beaucoup plus
en faisant des évacuations sanitaires
pour ramener nos concitoyens des
territoires ultramarins vers l'hexagone
et vers des spécialistes qu'ils n'ont
pas alors que l'on devrait développer de
l'implantation de spécialistes sur la
totalité du territoire pendant une
énorme problème d'immigration
clandestine et mais s'arrêter et noyé
par l'émigration clandestine il ya aussi
un problème d'immigration vous avez tout
à fait raison sur c'est sur ces deux
territoires mais il n'empêche qu'il ya
un problème de santé que je voulais
souligner et si on veut réduire le reste
à charge sur les médicaments comme sur
les autres
prothèses c'est à dire la prothèse
auditive le dentaire et l'optique quand
je parle de l'optique c'est évidemment
la monture et le vert ce que je souhaite
moi c'est d'avoir une clarification de
la relation entre la sécurité sociale
les mutuelles et les professionnels
qu'ils soient les prothésistes où les
médecins aujourd'hui vous avez un reste
à charge qui est très important beaucoup
trop important pourquoi parce qu'on a
des contrats types qu'on ne peut pas
comparer et à c'est une réforme très
pragmatique moi je veux qu'on ait trois
contrats types pour tous les concitoyens
un contrat
moyen un contrat qui couvre tout est un
contrat renforcé qu'on puisse comparer
aujourd'hui pour celles et ceux qui nous
écoutent je vous défie allait essayer de
voir votre voisin est de comparer votre
contrat de couverture c'est impossible
de savoir si on est mieux couverts au
moins bien parce que on couvre pas la
même chose donc on va tous se mettre
autour de la table et je me suis donné
le quinquennat pour pouvoir avoir une
prise en charge à 100% des siens dernier
point quand on parle de 3000 d'aborder
notamment travis va être hélas et la
prévention je suis aussi tout à fait
d'accord pour la fin du numerus clausus
le problème c'est que ça prendra dix ans
pour avoir pour former des médecins mais
derrière on doit tout faire pour
améliorer la prévention dans les écoles
dans les maisons de retraite c'est pour
ça que dans les formations des médecins
je souhaite qu'ils aient un trimestre
dédiée à la prévention voilà je vous
demande de m'aider mais vous parlez de
vous parler de ça de prévention et ça
vous apporte nuit dans la loi elle comme
riz d'effondrer mais la santé pr vellas
maquereau en milieu professionnel ça
s'appelle la loi macron mais la loi
macron la loi macron elle s'appelle pas
la loi macron non le vol comme puisque
vous avez pas voulu assumer mais c'est
la vie normale des lois macron pour
hisser la loi makpénon banon donc c'est
vraiment avec nom et omri a les bons
dans la loi macro elcom rit on voit bien
que en l'occurrence la protection de la
santé dans l'entreprise et bien s'est
effondré voilà parce que vous ne donnez
plus les moyens parce qu'on retire les
moyens précisément de pouvoir permettre
de faire de la prévention pour les
salariés que on a diminué ces moyens que
donc on diminue les visites médicales et
ce à savoir avoir une conséquence
extrêmement grave sur la prévention et
dont vous parlez par ailleurs mais que
manifestement dans les faits eh bien
vous n'entendez pas mettre en oeuvre
merci on va avancer maintenant je
voudrais de répondre très précisément et
réclamant à une question à quel âge les
français doivent-ils partir à la
retraite à 60 ans avec 40 annuités 60
ans ils ont 40 annuités
moi c'est très clair et quand
60 ans quand ils ont 40 annuités votre
élection si vous êtes élu non je
m'engage à ce que ce soit le cas d'ici
la fin du quinquennat présent simple non
non ça va pas changer puis j'en ai deux
mois il ya quelques semaines mais bon ça
a dû changer dans les deux mois oui vous
aviez dit dès que je suis élu il a vous
avez d'un seul coup chars le schéma cran
et que tu as excusez moi mais parler de
vos projets mais on se connaissait mal
alors un sourire inspiré vois je verrai
où vous même madame loïk très clairement
le plus vite sera le mieux le plus vite
sera le mieux parce que l'idée qu'on
demande toujours des sacrifices aux
français en toutes circonstances en leur
expliquant et en les culpabilisant
d'ailleurs c'est votre grandes
spécialités objectivement si notre
régime de retraite ne fonctionne pas
c'est à cause d'eux parce qu'ils
travaillent pas assez longtemps c'est
parce que ils ne travaillent pas assez
il ya toujours un phénomène de
culpabilisation des français en toute
circonstance et d'ailleurs si son
chômage monsieur mâcon vous leur dites
c'est de votre faute c'est parce que
vous acceptez pas les offres qui vous
sont faites et c'est la raison pour
laquelle d'ailleurs vous voulez
supprimer en réalité limitée
l'indemnisation du chômage en expliquant
que et bien on leur fera deux offres on
sait pas où on sait pas de quoi se
trouve à 200 km ou à 300 clavier de
parler projets si au bout de deux fois
et si au bout de deux fois ils disent
non et bien ils n'auront plus
d'indemnisation chômage et bien moi
cette culpabilisation des français je ne
la supporte plus les français n'ont
aucune raison de culpabiliser j'avais
son talent en creux raison si notre
système mais ils auront le droit qu'on
ne les prennent pas pour des imbéciles
non plus on peut terminer ou oui mais
allez-y mais parler de votre projet
comme vous le disiez vous parlez pas de
votre projet sur les retraites ça on
peut merci voilà donc si le système le
régime de retraite aujourd'hui est en
grande difficulté ce n'est pas de la
faute des français 7 2 votre faute c'est
la faute du système qui vous soutient
monsieur mâcon c'est celui qui a été au
pouvoir depuis des années des années qui
a mis en place un modèle économique qui
a entraîné un chômage de masse car le
seul moyen est un très bon moyen de
sauver le système de retraites c'est de
retrouver la voie de l'emploi la
retraite à 60 ans avec 40 annuités c'est
17 milliards de coûts baisser le chômage
de 3 points ces 25 milliards de recettes
pour l'état sauf que ça vous avez été
incapable de le faire parce qu'encore
une fois le modèle économique soumis à
la mondialisation sauvage l'ouverture
totale des frontières la concurrence de
tous contre tous eh bien ça ça entraîne
le chômage de masse que nous vivons
aujourd'hui il faut donc rompre avec ce
modèle la mettre en place les
protections contre la mondialisation se
réarmer face à la mondialisation est
ainsi avec effectivement notre tissu
économique nos tpe pme retrouver la voie
de l'emploi faire baisser le chômage et
sauver ce système de retraite par
répartition auquel nous sommes si
attachés votre proposition je la connais
elle consiste à faire un mot d'un régime
unique ça fait très longtemps que c'est
dans les cahiers des ultralibéraux un ce
régime unique parce que en fait ce sera
la baisse généralisée mais oui bien
entendu et notamment ce sera la fin des
complémentaires c'est à dire que le
privé les cadres vont évidemment
beaucoup souffrir de cette mesure c'est
la fameuse retraite à points on l'avait
trouvé chez monsieur fignon aussi un
décidément vous avez des points communs
quand il s'agit de mettre en place des
mesures ultra bill très libérale telle
que celle-là avec votre réforme à vous
des retraites mais macron donc
globalisation des systèmes comme l'a dit
mme marine le pen on partira à la
retraite à quel âge alors d'abord madame
le pen propose de partir à 60 ans donc
elle proposait naguère qu' on puisse le
faire dès son élection maintenant elle a
reporté la chose ça coûte 30 milliards
17 ça coûte 30 milliards 7,1 finançable
c'est ce qu'avait été ce qui avait été
fait au début des années 80 par françois
mitterrand et à une époque où
l'espérance de vie était de dix ans
inférieure à celle d'aujourd'hui donc à
la fin des saints savez y ait pas de
finances magique les retraites moi je
propose de garder un système par
répartition ce sont les actifs qui paye
les retraites des retraités et donc
quand on fait une mesure comme madame le
pen soit on va augmenter les cotisations
soit on va baisser les pensions mais on
peut pas expliquer aux gens on va vous
payer pour tout le monde la retraite à
60 ans y compris pour des gens qui sont
derrière un bureau qui ont pas de
pénibilité forcément comme les autres
qui ont commencé à 25 28 ans parce qu'on
commence plus tard la carrière vous leur
dites à 60 ans bon très bien c'est très
généreux c'est peut-être tout à fait
louable mais vous n'expliquez pas
comment vous le financer et dans toutes
les hypothèses kylie a évidemment que la
baisse du chômage est prise en compte
mais vous n'avez pas non plus expliquer
comment vous allez baisser le chômage on
a vu tout à l'heure vous ne proposez
rien donc moi je le dis simplement la
réforme des retraites de madame le pen
sait où l'augmentation des cotisations
ou la baisse des pensions moi ce que je
propose c'est de garder un système mais
de le faire d'avoir un système juste je
ne propose pas du tout touché aux
complémentaires ou autre donc ne mentait
pas aux gens qu'au régime unique césar
non pas sur la base qui soit le même
pour tout le monde il ya 37 régime de
base qui sont différents ça n'est plus
acceptable et nos concitoyens ne le
comprennent plus ne l'acceptent plus un
artisan un commerçant il comprend plus
un agriculteur qui est à la msa il fait
plus aujourd'hui d'avoir le système
général à côté de lui d'avoir les
régimes spéciaux qui sont beaucoup plus
avant l âge de départ sera le même pour
tous et donc je ne change pas pour le
quinquennat à venir l'année de départ je
ne change pas le niveau de cotisation je
ne change rien et toutes celles et ceux
qui sont à cinq ans du départ je ne
change rien pour après je mets en place
un système qui montera progressivement
en charge tous les droits acquis sont
maintenus et chacun ensuite cotisera une
nouvelle année dans le système et le
système aura un pilotage qui sera
négocié chaque année où on décide de
manière responsable parce qu'il ya pas
de finances magique est-ce que vous êtes
prêts ou à augmenter les cotisations ou
à décaler l'âge ce sera décidé très vite
du medef salon ce sera des pas du tout
le medef comme monsieur fillon n'était
pas du tout sûr c'est à dire madame
parisot va peut-être premier ministre en
fait des longues ce serait bien que j'ai
une bonne chance à vous faire non pas en
soit voilà il ira alors venant à tarder
non plus mais allez-y faites votre
fantasme a peut-être mal gré sur la
plupart et noires de l'appareil vous
répondre mais c'est l'équipe en question
ces formations sont les thèmes qui
intéressent mais
toute façon oui la preuve vous avez
connu beaucoup dont il a d'abord été
annoncée avant je voulais parce qu'on
nous accuse important est de savoir
accuse un gardien pour tous cas la main
savait avant tout se met à table on nous
accuse de pas parler de fond de temps en
temps il faut c'est très important un
sujet c'est pas qui préoccupe les
marchés on reste dans un système de
répartition qui est plus juste et plus
transparent alors et qui est lui est
financée comme est rarement là outre à
propos de sécurité terroristes comme un
sujet qui préoccupe énormément les
français la france a été touché par de
nombreux attentats et u2 loi sur le
terrorisme et le renseignement qui ont
été adoptés vivons encore aujourd'hui
sous le régime de l'état d'urgence
j'aurais savoir quelles sont vos
propositions marine le pen dans ce
contexte actuel très concrète la
sécurité le terrorisme est un une
problématique absolument majeur
totalement absente de votre projet
totalement absente aucune proposition
qui tienne la route c'est à dire que la
sécurité physique de nos compatriotes et
la lutte contre le terrorisme et le
fondamentalisme islamiste vous ne voulez
pas le mener vous voulez pas le mener
monsieur macro moi je sais pourquoi
contre le terrorisme il faut d'abord
retrouver nos frontières nationales tout
de suite immédiatement et ça ce sera
quelque chose que je ferai immédiatement
après mon arrivée au pouvoir
il faut que l'on excuse tout de suite
les fichiers s étrangers qui sont sur
notre territoire tout ce qui est
étranger sur notre territoire italien
que le fondamentalisme islamiste d'or
d'or tous ceux qui sont 12 le nacional
do doubles nationaux on mettra en oeuvre
la déchéance nationale je sais que vous
êtes contre cela mais vous êtes pour
toutes les propositions de laxiste et
contre toutes celles qui font preuve de
fermeté vous me laisserez expliqué mon
projet dans la durée ou d'envié et
déchus de leur nationalité ils seront
également va alors faire valoir un pur
sucre enfonce dans la vente de t d
filiale est terrorisée dans la déchéance
qui est un débat qui a déjà eu lieu le
président de la république a voulu le
faire sa règle rien au sujet mais c'est
tout continuer quelqu'un qui se fait
sauter puisque aujourd'hui les
terroristes que nous devons combattre et
que gerra décret ce sont des gens qui se
suicident dans les attentats on l'a vu
vous vous attendez là vous attendez
l'attentât vous mais pas maintenant pas
rationnel sommes pas là tu es moi
j'attends pas d'attentats simplement
quelqu'un qui est dans cette disposition
d'esprit la déchéance de nationalité
brandie par madame le pen vous pensez
que ça le fait trembler il faut aller
beaucoup plus au coeur beaucoup plus au
fond être beaucoup plus on crée la 200
sur sa des principes allant pas de lait
sont en effet donc avant avant qu'ils
aient commis l'attentât avant tes
chances dan assiettée expulsion
immédiate voilà déjà tout cela ils sont
plus sur le territoire et donc nos
policiers des gendarmes peuvent
continuer à surveiller un nombre qui
soient limités personne parce que
arriver quand même à l'excès sur le
territoire le schéma compte 11000
fichier s pour fondamentalisme islamiste
onze mille et ça c'est aussi le bilan de
votre gouvernement c'est une véritable
honte le lendemain de l'attentât
vous avez dit je vais pas inventer quand
même un programme dans la nuit contre le
terrorisme c'est à dire que vous vous
présenter à l'élection présidentielle je
lui mets vins même pas les matelas les
consignes et les jeunes au sérieux comme
vous dans le siège des sauts de cabri
laisser terminant puisque a constamment
vous êtes dans l'affectif les nerfs
parler je ne suis certes pas venir jouer
madame le pen regardez je suis en
chantier du retard sur vous et vous
allez le rattrapent leur laissez moi
parler parler de votre projet ne dis pas
de bêtises sur le mien j'ai un projet
mais simplement réagit pas aux
événements comme vous n'avez pas de
projet les antilles site non seulement
vous n'avez pas de projet mais en plus
vous avez une complaisance pour le
fondamentalisme islamiste c'est ça
peut-être le blé flotter va proposer sur
ce qu'il faut c'est arrivé un
développer vos compositions monsieur
mabut va aller mieux et les îles
mais parce que vous me couper la parole
toutes les dix secondes à peu près je
vous sens un peu agacé je pense qu'il
faut s'attaquer à la racine du mal à la
racine du mal c'est de développement
exponentiel du fondamentalisme islamiste
sur notre territoire
il faut évidemment fermer les mosquées
salafistes il faut expulser les
prêcheurs de haine il faut aussi
s'attaquer aux associations qui vous
soutiennent monsieur macron comme le f
liu wei f cell l'union des organisations
islamiques de france non c'est l'union
des organisations islamistes de france
car en réalité c'est une association
islamiste qui défend le fondamentalisme
islamiste qui soutient monsieur macron
qui a invité à chacun de ces congrès
vous entendez à chacun de ces congrès
des gens qui sont venus exprimer leur
haine des juifs leur haine des
homosexuels leur haine des mécréants et
qui tiennent systématiquement des
discours de haine je suis hani ramadan
qui justifie la lapidation des femmes il
vous a soutenu aussi et quand on vous a
dit qu'on veut maintenant quand on vous
allez monsieur match et maintenant les
messieurs malgré cet important que les
français sachent où ils auraient je vous
réponds c'est un peu a poursuivi ce vote
alors ça vous a dit et lorsqu'on vous a
dit monsieur macron mais vous acceptez
le soutiennent lui y est vous aviez
voulu ça me pose pas de problème donc
tous les gens qu'ils ont qu'ils ont reçu
dans leur congrès et qui tiennent des
propos qui sont des véritables appels au
meurtre et bien non pas l'air de vous
déranger et bien ça je pense que cette
très révélateur est extrêmement
problématique donc il faut s'attaquer à
l'intégralité de ces associations qui
sont en réalité les faunes et les faux
nez du salafisme les faux nez des frères
musulmans il faut arrêter les
financements étrangers de la part de
pays comme schéma qu'on connaît bien le
qatar l'arabie saoudite
puisque vous aviez fait
à l'époque vous aviez maintenu des
exonérations fiscales pour les
investissements de ces pays en france
vous avez d'ailleurs je crois votre
gouvernement a accordé une récompense
républicaine dernièrement un de ses
responsables il faut éradiquer
l'idéologie du fondamentalisme islamiste
dans notre pays et vous ne le ferez pas
vous ne le ferez pas parce que vous êtes
soumis à monsieur macron parce que ils
vous tienne voilà c'est aussi simple que
cela c'est malheureux à dire c'est
terrifiant car ça peut avoir des
conséquences extrêmement lourdes sur les
français mais on l'a vu avec la faire ça
ou clairement vous avez été mis devant
le dire le chantage soit vous gardiez
monsieur ça ou qui est un radical
islamiste soient lieu hier à pellets à
vous faire battre et vous avez préféré
conserver ce soutien plutôt que de
prendre le risque d' exprimer votre
condamnation la plus formelle de ces
dérives qui sont des dérives extrêmement
lourde qui font des morts sur notre
territoire qui ont commis des attentats
multiples et contre lequel aujourd'hui
rien de sérieux en réalité n'a été fait
parce que les lois c'est que ce soit
disant pour la sécurité les lois
renseignements que vous nous apprenez à
cobo mais pourquoi ils n'ont pas été
votées par vous découvrirez pourquoi je
l'assumé comme un terreau élèves au
parlement allemand c'est du bidon total
il s'agissait de surveiller tout le
monde pour ne pas avoir précisément à
surveiller sont ceux dont nous savons
puisqu'ils sont fichier est ce que il
représente un danger et puis au delà de
saint pardon il y a le laxisme
judiciaire et qui fait que l'explosion
de l'insécurité que j'appelle
quotidienne est aujourd'hui un poids
insupportable non seulement dans les
villes mais également dans les campagnes
alors il faut que les peines soient
prononcées il faut que les peines
prononcées soient appliquées il faut
créer non pas 15 milles mais 40000
places de prison monsieur macron et puis
pour libérer un certain nombre de places
tout de suite il faut passer des accords
bilatéraux avec les pays dont sont issus
les étrangers qui sont incarcérés dans
notre pays pour qu'ils halles pour
qu'ils aillent peuvent faire leur peine
dans leur pays d'origine voilà un plan
avec la remise en oeuvre du
renseignement qui est un à vaudrey port
absolument complet pour lutter en même
temps contre la délinquance et le
terrorisme étant entendu qu'il vous a
pas échappé les deux en réalité sont
aujourd'hui systématiquement liés c'est
ce qu'on appelle l'hybridation alors à
vous de répondre emmanuel macron le
terrorisme et la menace terroriste c'est
la priorité des prochaines années la
priorité
je veux être président de la république
française donc je veux être chef des
armées est en charge de cette sécurité
donc ce sera ma priorité
cela suppose de renforcer les moyens de
police et d'avoir une action en effet
avant que les attentats n'intervienne et
donc sur les fichiers s ce sont des
fichiers de renseignement en la matière
je suis pour renforcer les mesures y
compris les mesures qui peuvent être
privative de liberté sur les fichiers
est liée à des activités djihadistes
mail à tous les professionnels vous le
dise ce sont des fichiers de
renseignements avec si vous croisez un
djihadiste vous pouvez être fichés
est-ce donc tous les mettre en prison où
tous les mettre hors des frontières
n'aurait pas de sens au demeurant je
rappelle qu'il n'ya qu'un quart des
terroristes depuis 2012 non la mesure
générale nom puisqu'elle ne permettrait
pas d'avoir une vraie réponse en matière
de renseignement ce qui est la priorité
pour faire les
vétérans tue les cellules et rouler
j'essaie de comprendre important que je
dis depuis le début des attentats un
quart étaient fichés s1 car donc la clé
c'est d'améliorer l'enseignement de le
renforcer tous ceux qui sont identifiés
il faut renforcer en effet les choses et
pour certains les expulser mais je suis
sur une mesure beaucoup plus
chirurgicale est pas une mesure générale
comme madame le pen qui ne permettrait
pas à nos forces de police de travail et
je veux reconstituer les forces de
renseignement le renseignement
territoriale a été démantelé il faut
aller beaucoup plus loin sur le
territoire on l'a encore vu à la réunion
l'autre joue tous nos territoires sont
touchés par la menace terroriste donc
l'effort de renseignement doit être fait
sur le territoire est partout avec un
lien renforcé sur le renseignement cyber
c'est à dire sur internet et pour
coordonner cela au mieux pour prévenir
plutôt que guérir
je créerai une task force une cellule
auprès du président de la république est
pas une agence comme vous le proposez
près du premier ministre qui coordonnera
les services de renseignement c'est la
mère des batailles ensuite la fermeture
des frontières et le reste sert à rien
il y à des pays nombreux trop nombreux
malheureusement qui ne sont pas dans
schengen qui ne sont pas soumis à tous
ceux qui ont été frappés de la même
façon que nous par les attentats et par
le terrorisme et d'ailleurs j'ai une
nouvelle pour vous depuis novembre 2015
schengen le permet nous avons rétabli
des contrôles aux frontières pour lutter
contre les terroristes qui ont permis
l'interpellation de plus de soixante dix
mille personnes donc ce que vous
proposez comme d'habitude c'est de la
poudre de perlimpinpin
mais derrière la clé c'est d'aller sur
le terrain identifier toutes celles et
ceux qui constituent une menace les
terroristes qui passent pas la frontière
tous les jours en se signalant ils sont
dans nos aéroports dans nos gares il
circule ils sont sur internet ils mènent
des réseaux c'est le renseignement et
c'est la coopération entre les
différents états c'est pour cela que
nous avons besoin d'une plus grande
coopération entre les états membres de
l'union européenne il y a eu des
avancées ces derniers temps ce qu'on
appelle le pnr pouvoir sur des fichiers
contrôlée justement les potentiels
terroristes qui circulent de l'un à
l'autre et en est loin et on l'a vu
qu'ils prennent l'avion on l'a vu
l'avion c'est bien à part il y en a
beaucoup plus qu'ils passent les
frontières en se signalant madame le pen
vous avez voté contre de ces parlement
européen ce que ça serait bien sûr que
ça ne sert à rien allez-y répéter le
rire ce qu' il n'y a pas eu d'attentât
dans les aéroports avait pas eu de
tentative d'attentât dans les aéroports
mais vous en avez beaucoup voient la
frontière prenez pas l'avion et personne
n'avait été contre mais non mais madame
le pen vous avez été contre toutes les
réformes que l'union européenne
apportait pour lutter contre le
terrorisme tout nul mais vous ne
proposez ça rien à côté de ça le
rétablissement aux frontières on va
mettre quoi des gardes à douanières mais
est elle vous sérieuse ou riche et très
sérieuse très va mettre des noyers qui
vont lutter contre les terroristes on va
mettre des douaniers qui vont surveiller
nos veillées moi je connais les oignons
sont des fonctionnaires est remarquable
remarquable mais ils ne sont pas formés
pour lutter contre le terrorisme n'est
pas leur coeur de métier et les tirs au
but face au sco des terroristes et vont
les arrêter mais ils ne vont pas les
arrêter parce que ces terroristes ils
fonctionnent par internet parce qu'ils
vont prendre d'autres moyens mais c'est
tellement alors justement j'aime que
c'est irréaliste ce sujet selon
christine pardon m alors je lui réponds
quand même sur le relief jmicron vous
avez dit la france a une part de
responsabilité dans le terreau du jihad
vous cliquez sur votre pensée je vais
d'abord démanteler les bêtises que vous
avez dit tout à l'heure lui aussi est
rapidement parce que oui non mais parce
que ce sont des assertions donc voila
moi j'ai un projet sérieux qui n'est pas
du saut de cabri et moi j'ai toujours
pris mes responsabilités contrairement à
madame le pen qui elle fait de la lutte
contre le terrorisme sur les plateaux
mais elle est payée par le contribuable
pour être député européen il est vrai
qu'elle y va très peu à chaque fois
qu'il ya des réformes importantes dans
ce sens là elle ne les votes sont noyés
après ses vacances sur l'île à la grèce
lieu eev c'est simple si l'unef
prononce invite même des activités qui
sont contraires aux lois de la
république je la ferai interdire je ne
connais pas les dirigeants de lyon f je
ne les ai jamais rencontrés et à ma
connaissance le dernier parti politique
qui a eu maille à partir avec eux et qui
les a fait participer à des colloques
c'est le front national avec monsieur
aliot donc balayer devant chez vous mais
ne venez pas me chercher là dessus ces
gens là vous ne les connais pas avait
pas ces gens là je ne les connais pas
l'organe en relation le dire moi mais je
n'ai pas de relations avez vous le dire
est ce que je vous dis qui est dans mon
projet eelv où furent vous soutiens à
lui vous avez dit que vous acceptiez ce
soutien mais madame le pen soit ils ne
respectent pas les lois de la république
et dans ces cas-là porté plainte contre
eux porté plainte contre eux faites le
adacore demain moi si je suis élu
président de la république j'interdirais
jeu démantèlerait de manière impitoyable
toutes les associations et pas pour
l'instant je ne suis pas président de la
république pour l'instant vous acceptez
leur soutien comme candidat mme le pen
est ce qu'il est ce qu ils font des
choses sacrées cynisme comme aux lois de
la république n'ont ce cynisme c'est le
vôtre après chaque session aller
chercher dans vos archives rate ce n'est
pas chez martine à bulle si ça n'est pas
chez moi du congrès en relief du nord en
2016 vous parlez de chant voilà il dit
l'homosexualité conduit à la destruction
de l'homosexuel c'est pour cette raison
mes chers frères le châtiment de
l'homosexualité et la peine de mort mais
c'est formidable de voir des fontaines à
fond dames et jeunes musulmans de france
intervenant au congrès de l'unef 2017
dont [ __ ] même pas retourné très très
loin qualifié les juifs d'avoir aidé
usuriers ou d'être le top de la trahison
et de la félonie dans une conférence
révélée par le journal l'humanité c'est
ces gens là dont vous acceptez le
soutien mais vous dites j'attendrai
d'être président madame l'aller nick
d'abord je trouvais j'espère que vous ne
serez jamais président de l'arrivée pas
un mérite formidable c'est de pouvoir
vous entendre tenir des propos de
compassion avec les homosexuels et les
juifs de ce pays je trouve ça formidable
et je m'en félicite parce que pour ma
part je les ai toujours protégé d'autre
part sur lieu hier protégez moi je vous
le dise dissoute non lieu y est je ne
sous traite maintenant le
fondamentalisme islamique j'espère que
vous plaisantez monsieur madame le pen
depuis je n'ai pas avec ça je ne
plaisante pas justement ne mentez pas
des gens que les fans avec ça je ne
soutiens pas lu rieff mais je vous dis
et je vous redis vous avez accepté le
mental ray toutes les associations
toutes les associations qui invitent à
la violence à la haine à la division et
qui font le jeu des vous avez accepté
les ouvriers dans mon programme mais
vous avez acheté le jeu serait un déluge
fc chez vous qu'elle va réaliser blé ne
soutiens chez moi madame fn et vous avez
derniers mois vous avez dit dans un une
émission au sol et de vous le dire que
cessent les siens mais madame le pen il
ya plus que ça mais chez moi s'il
regarde les cadres qui a fondé d'accord
avec dany phare de ré ce que mediapart a
encore révélé aujourd'hui la savoyarde
qui a fait une traction va mener à
lafarge et des ch mais c'est vous ce
sont vos responsables ans a une part de
responsabilité dans le terreau du
jihadisme telle est sa venue va pouvoir
y répondre avec la question suivante est
ce sa nouvelle macro et marine le pen
s'il vous plaît justement que fait-on
des jeunes français qui se radicalise
sur notre territoire savait pas dire
quoi s'appuyait non madame le pen vous
pouvez me laisser répondre de manière
posée aux choses je vous remercie parce
que ces débats sont sérieux ce ne sont
pas des débats d'insinuations surtout
sur des sujets où votre parti ramaël est
ambigu je ne suis pas mal à l'aise du
temps ce que j'ai dit c'est pourquoi des
jeunes français se radicalise c'est la
question qu'on doit collectivement se
poser et vous avez raison c'est avec
lille c'est à cause de la france madame
le pen je sais ce que j'ai dit je n'ai
pas dit ça je n'ai pas dit ça ne mentez
pas une fois encore j'ai dit on doit
s'interroger quand des jeunes français
ou des jeunes françaises qui sont nés en
france qui ont grandi en france qui ont
été élevés dans notre pays suivent des
fanatiques et détruisent nos propres
enfants on doit s'interroger et j'ai dit
nous avons notre part de responsabilité
c'est pas la première cause la cause
première ce sont les djihadistes ce sont
les terroristes c'est pour ça d'ailleurs
que je veux mener une guerre intraitable
hors de nos frontières est la part de
rêve contre l'irak et la syrie la
question c'est de s'arrêter est ce que
vous pouvez me répondre
parce que ce sont des sujets importants
c'est de savoir comment des enfants qui
sont nés dans la république en arriver
là ça veut dire qu'il y à des malades
psychiatriques et qu'on ne les suit plus
mais il y en a et ça a été à plusieurs
fois relevé chez les terroristes donc il
faut là dessus malades psychiatriques
maintenant il est déséquilibré oui il y
à des déséquilibrés on le sait bien dans
celles et ceux qui se radicalise et donc
il faut là dessus avoir un travail un
travail préventif qui est indispensable
et la deuxième chose c'est que notre
république doit donner une place à
chacune et chacun et c'est fondamental
nous devons dans le même temps mené
lutte intraitable avoir une tolérance
zéro à l'égard du terrorisme hors de nos
frontières et dans nos frontières et
s'assurer que chacune et chacun y trouve
une place or notre république elle ne
donne plus une place à tous nos jeunes l
enclave elle assigne à résidence des
jeunes par l'échec scolaire par l'échec
économique et sociale et donc nous avons
là dessus une part de responsabilité
quand des enfants de la république
faisons notre propre examen de
conscience tourne ainsi et décide de
détruire la république qui les a nourris
regardons-nous en face et c'est là où
pour moi c'est presque le plus important
en tant que chef des armées en tant que
responsable de la sécurité je serai
intraitable et je mènerai la lutte sur
tous les plans contre le terrorisme
islamiste mais ce qu'ils attendent le
piège qui nous tendent c'est celui que
vous portez c'est la guerre civile ce
que ce qu'attendent les terroristes
c'est que nous nous divisions ce
qu'attendent les terroristes c'est le
discours de haine et ça n'est pas un
hasard d'ailleurs monsieur kepel qui est
un universitaire de renom l'a redit ce
matin abou moussa d' en 2005 dans un
texte qui fait référence pour les
terroristes il dit quoi le plus grand
souhait qu'on peut avoir c'est que
madame le pen arrive au pouvoir en
france le plus grand souhait pourquoi
pas ce qu'ils cherchent la
radicalisation la division la guerre
civile que vous portez dans le pays
lutter contre les terroristes ça n'est
en aucun cas céder à leurs pièges
le piège de la guerre civile celui qu
ils nous tendent celui que vous portez
en divisant les français en insultant
les françaises et les français à cause
de leur religion en jetant le trouble
dans notre pays et cela je ne le ferai
jamais jamais m'entendais vous le
pratiquez marine jamais absolument
jamais de toute mon existence insulté
quiconque à raison ni de son origine ni
de sa religion monsieur macron mais tout
ça est à une vieille litanie des jeunes
à l'extérieur mais vieux l'intérieur ce
que vos arguments le double de votre âge
mais enfin ça c'est pas très grave en
l'occurrence moi je te plaît
s'il vous plaît je fais attention
n'avait pas sur ce temps là vous non
plus je crois mon nom mon nom n'y avait
pas non il se défend la france y aller
on va réussir à trouver un point de
connexion je défends la france en toute
circonstance est ce que vous croyez pas
que vous avez vous une part de
responsabilité dans la haine qui se
développent chez un certain nombre de
jeunes à l'égard de la france quand vous
allez en algérie pour accuser la france
de crimes contre l'humanité crimes
contre l'humanité c'est-à-dire le crime
le plus grave qui puisse exister
vous êtes allez vous qui voulait être
président de la république en algérie à
l'étranger donc pour aller dire la
france a commis un crime contre
l'humanité mais alors comment vous
étonnez vous qu'un certain nombre de
jeunes 10 mai puisque la france a commis
un crime contre l'humanité contre nous
pourquoi est ce qu'on ne vient pas lui
faire payer son crime est-ce que vous ne
croyez pas que vous avez une
responsabilité considérable lorsque vous
tenez ce genre de propos sur la haine
quand un certain nombre de jeunes à
l'égard du pays où ils vivent ou même à
l'égard pour certains du pays dont ils
ont la nationalité et vos propositions
marine le pen sur justement lui la lutte
contre la radicalisation des plus jeunes
français mais clé c'est extrêmement
simple la radicalisation ça doit être
gérée par les tribunaux alors encore une
fois on arrête toutes les associations
sportives
sociales culturelles qui en réalité se
sont développées partout sur nos
territoires avec bien souvent la
complaisance des élus locaux d'ailleurs
parce que bon bah aux élections vient
voir les uns les autres et fait même
quand elle nous regarde avec l'islam non
monsieur oui c'est souvent sollicités
oui d'accord ok continue à faire de
l'électoralisme et moi je m'occupe manon
mais moi je parle de quelque chose qui
est extrêmement important qui est le
développement précisément de cette
pensée de cette idéologie
fondamentaliste qui recrutent sur notre
territoire en se servant de la faiblesse
dam de nos dirigeants ou en se fermant
de la en se servant de l'aveuglément
volontaire en réalité d'un certain
nombre d'élus locaux donc il faut couper
tout cela il ya un nombre inouï vous
savez d'associations sportives dans
lequel il y a des revendications
religieuses qui sont inadmissibles et
tout le monde ferme les yeux il y a
maintenant dans les entreprises et c'est
un peu grâce à vous monsieur macron bon
ou plutôt à cause de vous oui oui
puisque avec la loi elle comrie en
l'occurrence eh bien vous interdisait
aux chefs d'entreprises de pouvoir
éviter les revendications
communautaristes et les exigences
religieuses au sein de l'entreprise donc
toutes ces lois là toutes ses petites
lâchetés tout droit mais reculent tous
ces aménagements
raisonnable direz vous quand totalement
déraisonnable je dirais moi avec c'est
cet islam radical eh bien nous sommes en
train de le payer et de le payer très
cher et donc c'est évidemment avec une
fermeté totale qu'il faut agir et
objectivement quand j'entends monsieur
macron aller en algérie dira la france a
commis un crime contre l'humanité quand
je l'entends accepté le soutien de l'ue
aux lièvres cette association islamiste
qui accueille des prêcheurs de haine
quand j'entends monsieur hani ramadan
qui justifie la lapidation venir vous
soutenir gabriella moindre match sur des
beats je ne dis pas de bêtises non
monsieur ramadan si je ne le connais pas
ce qui nous est dit des grosses bêtes
seront non non et c'est des gros
mensonge ou absolument pas monsieur vous
irez voir nous avons capté l'écran
puisque vous l'avez peut-être demander
directement de retirer 100 tweets mais
en l'occurrence madame le recteur ce
soutien a été fait rien aucune parole de
votre part pour condamner cela bon eh
bien je dis qu'il ya une très forte
inquiétude à vous voir élu à la tête de
l'état arrive dessus de même jacques roy
le mensonge que vous cultivez et qui
nourrit la division du pays moi sur ces
sujets vous avez soulevé un sujet très
important la guerre d'algérie il y a eu
des drames durant cette guerre qui ont
touché nombre de nos concitoyens
les harkis les rapatrier vous avez très
foncée criminels non madame le pen je ne
vous laisserai pas dire ça mais il les
avait insultés de créer des drames et je
les ai vus les uns et les autres et qui
ont fait cette guerre d'algérie qui
aujourd'hui divise notre pays moi je
veux passer à une autre étape justement
je ne veux pas rester dans cette guerre
des mémoires et il faut regarder les
drames avait réouvert ses doigts
maintenant et je ne suis ni dans la
repentance envers ses plaies ni dans le
déni parce qu'il ya eu des vrais crimes
contre l'humanité en effet et vous avez
insultés beaucoup de françaises et
français lorsque vous êtes revenu sur la
rafle du vel d'hiv pour revenir
justement sur les propos courageux qui
avait tenu jacques chirac en 1995 et la
responsabilité de l'état français parce
que oui ce sont bien des policiers
français qui sont alors allés chercher
des juifs c'est la réalité ça c'est un
crime contre l'humanité donc moi je suis
pour regarder notre passé en face y
compris dans les pages les plus sombres
pour dire la vérité que nous devons à
tous nos concitoyens pour les
réconcilier pour avoir de l'unité est
pas cultiver les aime comme votre parti
d'extrême droite le fait depuis des
décennies parce qu'il s'en nourrit et
comme vous l'avez encore fait trop
récemment messieurs macron on va pas
avoir un débat juridique honnêtement sur
la rafle du vel d'hiv en l'occurrence
mieux vaut pour moi je considère que la
france était à londres j'ai cette
opinion qu'avait le général de gaulle
cac avait monsieur mitterrand car
aujourd'hui chevènement mais
généralement c'est qu'il a vraiment ko
si monsieur chevénement cas monsieur
guaino qui a toute une série de gens qui
considèrent que la france n'était pas
coupable de cet épouvantable horreur
mais qu' il s'agissait en l'occurrence
du régime de vichy s'est fié sur le
grand export sable et il venir alléger
les chirac non mais a reconnu jacques
chirac l'a reconnu mais jacques chirac
n'est pas non plus 20 on n'est pas
obligé de se mettre à la vision de
jacques chirac en l'occurrence beaucoup
de gens ont une vision juridique qui est
différente sur ce sujet et moi je trouve
que tout ce qui vise à alléger la
responsabilité du régime de vichy est à
mon sens en l'occurrence malvenue voilà
donc encore une fois faire cette
utilisation là monsieur m'a c'est vous
qui l'avez faire vous avez vous assez
révélateur s'est affaissé de leur
créateur de ce que vous faites déjà fait
tous les objets déjà une semaine de
confession juive ça les a tous blessés a
une nouvelle fois son nom d'alli
malheureusement non monsieur macron mais
vaut cette utilisation la mélodie n en
dit beaucoup sur vous qui en a parlé
elle en dit beaucoup sur vous qui en
avez parlé non c'est un journaliste qui
m'a posé la question monsieur oui c'est
vrai c'est un journaliste que vous
n'avez peut-être pas choisi que vous
avez des si vous interrogez librement
bonjour choisit pas beaucoup parce que
je sais que vous pouvez choisir mais moi
ça m'arrive jamais ce n'est pas moi qui
récusait un journal à naxos débat marine
le pen mails macron bas avance un peu
sur la sécurité au sens large est-ce que
vous pouvez nous dire concrètement parce
que tous les deux vous dit la même chose
la tolérance zéro la tolérance zéro
marine le pen c'est quoi pour vous la
tolérance zéro c'est que à chaque crime
- chaque délit évidemment il y à une
sanction il ya une solution qui
s'applique aujourd'hui avec les loi
taubira d'ailleurs en grande partie est
bien des peines peuvent être peuvent se
voir s'est substitué un certain nombre
de mesures sûrs alors ça va du bracelet
à venir une fois de temps en temps voir
le juge tiens on va peut-être pour
parler d'ailleurs des conséquences de ce
laxisme parce que monsieur chère fille
qui est le coupable de l'attentât qui a
tué xavier juge les il y a quelques
jours ben monsieur surfi il avait violé
son contrôle judiciaire ça faisait un an
et demi qu'il avait violé son contrôle
judiciaire il a été vu par un magistrat
et le magistrat lui a dit c'est pas bien
il faut arrêter de violer contrôle
judiciaire et puis le magistrat l'a
libéré et bien cette situation n'est pas
admissible donc moi je pense que il faut
que à chaque délit même si c'est un
délit qui apparaît comme une incivilité
il y ait une sanction pénale qui suivent
mais pour cela encore une fois il faut
que l'intégralité de la chaîne pénale
joue le jeu il faut que les magistrats
reçoivent un certain nombre
d'instructions notamment sur la
suppression de
sur le retour des peines plancher par
exemple sur notamment le renvoi dans
leur pays des étrangers condamnés parce
que la double peine ça a été supprimé un
certain nombre d'années ça veut dire
qu'aujourd'hui on est obligé d'accepter
sur notre territoire et même d'ailleurs
de subvenir aux besoins de ceux qui
sortent ans de prison et en ayant une
nationalité étrangère 12 restent sur le
territoire ça ce sont des choses qui
évidemment ne sont pas admissibles mais
pour ça il faut plus de magistrats je
suis désolé là aussi ça va faire des
dépenses monsieur macro meyzieu de l sur
les adhésions l'usiné pour celle-ci moi
aussi de plus de magistrats plus de
greffiers et surtout plus de places de
prison parce que aujourd'hui nous sommes
en situation non seulement de
surpopulation est en situation où un
nombre très important de criminels et de
délinquants ne met pas les pieds en
prison alors qu'ils sont condamnés à des
peines fermes mails vaqueront pour vous
la tolérance zéro ça signifie quoi c'est
d'abord 10000 postes de policiers et de
gendarmes en plus sur le territoire
parce que on a besoin sur le terrain
d'avoir ses moyens et des moyens aussi
donner à nos forces de police et de
gendarmerie on l'a encore vu avec les
crs qui ont été lâchement attaqué par
des militants d'extrême gauche qui ont
été gravement brûlées et auxquels je
pense ce soir on a besoin d'équipés
comme il se doit nos forces de l'ordre
ce soit les forces d'intervention où les
forces de sécurité quotidienne ce n'est
pas le cas aujourd'hui et donc là-dessus
j'assume totalement cet investissement
ensuite sur le terrain je veux
tolérance zéro à l'égard de la
délinquance du quotidien ce qui est
insupportable ce sont nos concitoyens
qui voit chaque jour des larcins qui ne
sont pas condamnés comme il se doit et
donc je veux recréer une police de
sécurité quotidienne qui connaît le
terrain qui est déployé sur le terrain
en permanence qui utilisent justement
ces nouveaux moyens et à laquelle je
donne de pouvoir qui aujourd'hui
n'existe pas et qui sont des sites
décisif à mes yeux un pouvoir d'amande
d'abord il faut que sur des délits du
quotidien qui n'ont pas de réponses
pénales aujourd'hui ils sont à 80 %
classée sans suite par exemple rappelle
appellerait lors des vols à l'étalagé
dans les allées dans le 93 regarder ce
que sans juge je veux qu'il y ait la
possibilité comme pour un délit routier
qu' il y ait un pouvoir d'amande c'est à
dire que vous avez un fonctionnaire de
police ou de gendarmerie
qui les sanctionnent en mettant une
amende sur un vol comme on le fait pour
les délits routiers madame le pen parce
que c'est aller chercher qui va aller
chercher le montant de l'amendé parce
que dans les zones de non droit que
votre gouvernement a laissé se
développer sur le territoire français où
les pompiers ne rentre plus les
policiers ne rentre plus que vous croyez
que les huissiers vous rentrez pour
venir chercher le paiement de l'amendé
qui aura été donné mais quand on fait
quand les délits routiers non mais l'anc
a parce que à weedon pour les délits
routiers bombay des routiers le général
les délits routiers touche les braves et
honnêtes citoyens qui eux sont
effectivement tondu que l'on fait payer
eux alors que les voyous qui vivent dans
des zones de non droit personne ne va
chercher les amendes auxquelles ils sont
condamnés à trappes c'est la ceinture
une grande injustice qui existe dans
notre pays monsieur macron il ya les
vaches à lait qui sont les
automobilistes et puis il ya les autres
qui encore une fois dans les cités dans
on ne rentre pas parce que ces cités
sont sous la responsabilité des caïds et
bien cela ils peuvent commettre tous les
délits possibles et imaginables alors on
ne va jamais à bloquer la peine quand
c'est une peine par exemple d'amande ou
une peine qui vise à réparer le
préjudice qu'ils ont commis à leurs
victimes donc je poursuis puisque madame
le pen a fait son petit chapitre qui
était prévu on peut reprendre le fil de
la discussion parce que vous avez dit
quelque chose qui n'a rien à voir avec
ce que j'étais en train de dire il y
aura la possibilité d'avoir des peines
d'amendés qui sont plus efficaces qu'un
classement sans suite parce que ce qui
est insupportable pour un policier
aujourd'hui qu'ils arrêtent un jeune qui
est en train de faire un vol à l'étalagé
ou qui détient des stupéfiants c'est que
il est déféré devant le juge après une
procédure qui est longue le lendemain il
est sur le terrain parce qu'il ya une
thrombose judiciaire et parce que vous
ne réglerez pas du jour au lendemain et
il est rappelé six mois un an plus tard
et dans les trois quarts des cas s'est
classée sans suite ou c'est un rappel à
la loi moi je ne veux plus là donc y
aura le pouvoir d'amande avec seal
amende mais pas réglé à ce moment là une
vraie procédure pénale avec des
contraintes et la possibilité également
d'éloigner les jeunes avant même le
délit du territoire lorsqu'il ya des
jeunes ou moins jeunes des bandes qui
crée des troubles près de la gare en bas
de l'immeuble qu'on connaît qu'on a
identifié auquel aujourd'hui on apporte
pas de réponse sauf un prendre en
flagrant délit il faut que nos forces de
police puissent avec l'autorisation du
juge dans une procédure très accéléré de
48 heures eh bien les enjoindre de ne
pas rester là c'est à dire s'ils sont là
le lendemain à ce moment là les
passionnés alors là pour le coup
monsieur vaqueront non c'est un peu
juste n'importe quoi ce que vous êtes
enfin non madame les jeunes
ça s'appelle l'injonction civile ça peut
être c'est une peine sa nouvelle donc
être appliquées que par un juge ce que
je viens de vous dire le mot il faut la
procédure accélérée de 48 heures on
trouve en dessous contre le jazz à
l'étagé
une personne obèse et monsieur maxence
iv souhaitez vous apprendre mais posons
excuses et madame le pen pourtant vous
avez bien portant est d'ailleurs
générale et apporte
jamais d'accord vous ai laissé avec
courtoisie terminer votre propos sur la
sécurité je vais terminer le mien voyez
avec la même courtoisie et terminer par
mercer très rapidement s'il vous plaît
donc outre ses moyens ou de cette police
de sécurité quotidienne outre ces
nouveaux moyens de coercition parce que
nos policiers en ont besoin très vite
sur leurs voeux que notre justice soit
intraitable et c'est pour cela qu'avec
moi toute peine prononcée sera exécutée
et je reviendrai sur la loi qui a fait
que pour toutes les peines de moins de
deux ans il n'ya pas d'exécution de
peine parce que c'est un signal entre
sur la loi taubira j'y reviendrai
totalement ma d'accord donc dans ce
programme madame taubira avait tort mais
bien évidemment il revient sur la loi
taubira prg ou
converser poser une question parce qu'il
pourra pas y répondre il en a pas tant
parce qu'on fera moins de rock c'est
dommage alors temps ça prend une minute
des policiers sont systématiquement
attaqués brûlé
on tente de les assassiner car ce qu'on
a vu hier mais aussi je viens d'en
parler moi même un nombre de scènes oui
c'est pour ça que je reviens dessus
ce sont des groupes des groupuscules
antifa wii qui sont organisés qui casse
tout en toutes circonstances est ce que
vous êtes pour leur dissolution je suis
pour la dissolution de tous les groupes
violents qui sont identifiés et connus
bon ben voilà il vous a répondu d'autres
et montrer ce que je suis pour que les
mesures ne pas
sortir madame le pen sur toute la
différence entre vous et moi on va pas
refaire le quinquagénaire héritière d'un
système d'un parti alors d'un non moi je
ne suis pas le vide ça on a cru qu'on se
rend vers ne ment jamais participé ou
pellets n'était pas d'accord et j'en
suis sorti j'ai démissionné j'ai quitté
un gouvernement la fonction publique
donc vous pouvez me renvoyer constamment
à tout ce qui a été fait durant les cinq
les dix les 15 dernières années alors je
répondrais de tout ce que j'ai fait moi
je ne répondrai à français s'il vous
plaît une avancée alors vous allez avoir
d'héritier
vendeurs qui vous soutient deux fois par
jour ainsi que de l'intégralité de vos
amis ministre avec lequel vous appelez
gouverneur
christie qualité des ministres
socialistes qui ont été vos collègues au
gouvernement comme la gestion
d'accès par début d'émission à cet
héritage tellement évident à tenir au
début
hollande
d'ailleurs une petit nom sûr que tout le
monde mais suite fut le début c'est pas
la peine de refaire le tribunal a dit
non à tout on va simplement dit elle
voulait juste que moi j'ai assumé où il
va parler d'europe je sais d'où je viens
d'international alors rompu a raconté
pas quand même ça mais arrêtons ces
blancs qui nous venons va vous croire en
fait même le pen les français allaient
les fronts à l'est à l'est ne sont pas
aussi bêtes aller alors comme ils sont
intelligents mis en valeur
alors magazine à leur séparation mais
non vous êtes parti pour pouvoir
organiser notre candidature celle du
système si pouvoir mettre en place les
conditions pour faire croire il fallait
que justement vous étiez on va d'abord
alors que vous étiez par les deux
candidats soient
entendus par les socialistes et par le
chine avait de quoi survivre car sinon
n'y aurait pas versé survivre vous
êtes à 30 secondes d'écart l'un et
l'autre on va parler d'europe avec
christophe et d'international et on
croit comprendre qu entre vous deux est
un sujet important donc ça mérite d'y
passer maintenant le petit vous en êtes
d'accord philatélie des questions
internationales qui vous divise
effectivement temps tous les deux on
commence bien entendu par l'europe dont
vous avez deux visions radicalement
opposées pouvez-vous chacun nous donner
votre définition de l'europe de demain
vous présidente marine le pen oui bien
entendu et bien l'union européenne aura
laissé la place à l'alliance européenne
des nations libres et souveraines c'est
à dire en réalité la vision qui était la
vision première de l'europe où les
différents peuples européens
conserveront leur souveraineté
c'est-à-dire la liberté de décider pour
eux-mêmes maîtrisons par exemple leurs
frontières et pourront décider qui entre
et qui n'entre pas sur leur territoire
aurons la maîtrise de leur monnaie pour
pouvoir adapter cette monnaie à leurs
économies pour éviter de se retrouver
avec la situation que nous connaissons
de chômage de masse et de perte de
compétitivité que monsieur macron
essayent de résoudre en proposant soit
de baisser les salaires soit des fonds
des systèmes d'indemnisation chômage
c'est-à-dire en fait le système de
protection sociale ou lorsque les
représentants des français dans le cadre
de la démocratie voteront les lois ces
lois auront une autorité supérieure aux
directives qui sont imposés par des
commissaires dont personne ne connaît le
nom dont personne ne connaît le visage
et surtout que personne n'a jamais
choisi et puis surtout nous retrouvons
la souveraineté économique c'est à dire
la liberté de faire du patriotisme
économique de donner un avantage à nos
entreprises françaises dans les marchés
publics de faire du protectionnisme
intelligent c'est à dire de mettre en
place les écluses qui sont nécessaires
pour que des productions ne vienne pas
nous concurrencer en faisant du dumping
sanitaire du dumping social du dumping
environnemental
et puis nous aurons aussi la maîtrise de
notre politique commerciale chez makro
jeu si vous êtes pour le cepd âge c'est
que vous êtes pour le taffetas c'est à
dire en réalité pour des accords de
libre échange qui nous sont imposées et
qui ne sont pas décidés par nous qui ont
des conséquences très lourdes sur notre
agriculture sur nos éleveurs mais aussi
sur nos industries et surtout des
conséquences très lourdes en matière de
santé on en a pas parlé tout à l'heure
puisque les productions qui arrive ainsi
sur notre marché ne sont évidemment pas
soumises aux mêmes normes de sécurité
que celles qui sont imposés à nos
industriels et à nos agriculteurs et qui
ont pour vocation bien entendu de
protéger la santé de nos compatriotes
donc je souhaite entrer en négociations
pour faire naître cette alliance
européenne organisé une conférence des
chefs d'état et de gouvernement un petit
peu sur le modèle de la conférence de
messine va faire parallèlement un
référendum constitutionnel que je
soumettrai aux français l'idée de caen à
le référendum constitutionnel ce sera en
septembre précisément en septembre ou
j'indiquerai que toute loi nouvelle aura
une autorité supérieure à le directive
eaux traitées en précédents européens
et puis parallèlement à cette
négociation je mettrai en place toutes
les mesures que je peux mettre en place
tout de suite sur le plan économique la
baisse des charges la baisse des impôts
la défiscalisation des heures
supplémentaires l'augmentation et la
valorisation des petites retraites etc
car tout ne dépend pas en l'occurrence
de l'union européenne mais des choses
essentielles nous bloque pour pouvoir
relancer notre notre économie et puis
vous savez il ya aussi la possibilité
c'est le compromis de luxembourg ya
aussi la possibilité d'aller à
l'encontre des règles européennes
monsieur macron lorsque les intérêts
vitaux du pays sont en jeu je crois que
par exemple c'est quelque chose qu'il
faudrait mettre en oeuvre pour arrêter
tout de suite la directive détachement
des travailleurs tout de suite parce que
celle ci
on a des conséquences très lourdes sur
l'emploi et donc il faut immédiatement
prendre parler précisément de leur vie
d'avant prendre cette décision et enfin
j'en termine et enfin j'en termine à
l'issue de ces négociations parce que
moi je ferai rien contre le peuple
français je n'aimerais pas faire ce qui
a été fait par vos amis socialistes et
vos amis ump d'ailleurs en 2005 à savoir
les français ont dit non à la
constitution européenne et malgré cela
on a dit oui à leur place je me
tournerai vers les français et je leur
livrerait l'issue de la négociation je
leur dirai voilà ce que j'ai réussi à
obtenir est ce que vous considérez que
c'est suffisant parce que vous
considérez que ça n'est pas suffisant et
sur ce choix aussi engageant pour
l'avenir de la france et l'avenir de
l'europe parce que moi je suis l'union
européenne je veux sauver l'europe
surtout arraché l'europe des mains de
l'union européenne qui est en train de
la tuer et bien je leur demanderai leur
avis et d'un centre bien de temps ce
taux reste ra percevez vous donnez
combien de temps et j'ai dit chez moi
c'est un délai indicatif d'autres ont
dit 18 mois c'est un délai indicatif
mais il faut moi je veux pas créer le
chaos je veux pas précipiter
s'il faut que six et dix mois ce sera 10
mois l'important c'est encore une fois
d'obtenir cette négociation pourquoi
pardon est juste jantes amis j'en ai
pour quelques secondes tu as quand vous
avez donné une interview
il y à quelque temps à un routeur le je
crois de mars où vous avez dit l'euro va
me va mourir dans les dix ans en gros
c'est ça l'euro va mourir de rire
bah je sais pas oui non mais en gros non
mais parce que vous dites toujours dire
que
jamais prêt si l esi poursuivi vous
dites vous dit si on ne fait pas une
europe fédérale totalement c'est à dire
est qu un gouvernement de la zone
européenne c'est-à-dire avec la perte de
notre souveraineté totale avec
l'intégralité des clés de la france
alors là pour le coup donné dans tous
les domaines de l'union européenne se
viande en gros budget l'impôt européen
etc alors l'euro alors pourra pas
survivre alors c'est votre solution ça
n'est pas la mienne je crois que ça
n'est pas celle des français que de
vouloir c'est ce bond en avant
fédéraliste qui est presque une forme
d'extrémisme mon pays ben oui parce que
dans tout va écouter dans tous les
candidats du premier tour excusé vol
vous étiez celui qui a exprimé la
position la plus radicale et la plus
extrémiste propose soumission d'un
fédéralisme européen marine le pen
justement de proposer un imac rond de
donner sa vision de l'europe y compris
du tout mais on va clarifier parce que
l'euro c'est important c'est la monnaie
pour nos concitoyens c'est pas qu'une
politique étrangère c'est pas que des
sujets abstraits c'est avec quoi on paye
on sort ou pas de l'euro il faut
retrouver notre lien offrant ou pas il
faut retrouver notre monnaie nationale
donc on revient en france est
essentielle instantiel essentielle vient
offrant donc vous proposer bien de
sortir de l'euro et non je veut
renégocier pour que l'euro on s'en
libère et on le transforme en monnaie
commune c'est ce qui lève existe c'est
ce qu'il a il était avant qu'il devienne
la monnaie de la france s'inspire avec
de l'euro que les choses soient très
claires non ne paiera pas et de l'europe
berceau des guerres où les banques
centrales perron avec de l'euro si elle
le souhaite bon les grandes entreprises
paieront avec l'euro si elle le souhaite
vous savez très bien salon qui aura deux
monnaies non pas pour les fous pas pour
les français pas pour les particuliers
pas pour les petites entreprises et vous
savez très bien né c'est quoi servira le
rôle est de créer cela mais aquarius
itunes morricone une c'est un panier de
2 de monnaie vous le savez en maintenant
une fois alors ça existait avant mais ça
existe et juste avant l'euro juste avant
que l'euro devienne notre monnaie ah bon
physique en france et oui et oui oui et
oui c'était l'euro déjà et avant lui
c'était les q donc les grandes
entreprises elles payer en euros en est
qu à vis de 93 à 2002 toutes les
entreprises pouvaient payer les grandes
entreprises pouvaient payer
effectivement en euros ce système a
parfaitement fonctionné monsieur macro
ne fait pas semblant de ne pas le savoir
non il y avait très bien il a fonctionné
dans le cadre du sm e et honnêtement
2,93 à 2002 c'était plutôt performant
mais c'est qu'il faut que les français
comprennent surtout c'est que à la
limite ça les regarde même pas cet euro
monnaie commune c'est une monnaie une
facilité entre les états c'est une
facilité pour les banques centrales mais
ça ne les touche pas elle maintenant eux
ils auront une monnaie mais les élus
sera de nous
vous parlez beaucoup madame mais vous
allez vous rattraper donc les français
ils ont une monnaie dans leur
portefeuille on a poussé une monnaie qui
permettra encore une fois de retrouver
un niveau adapté à notre économie et
donc de etc d'exporter à nouveau à des
donc de partir à la conquête du monde à
nouveau on a compris mais sachez que
l'euro a eu des conséquences très lourd
sur le pouvoir d'achat des français
puisque d'une sa mise en place a
entraîné une augmentation assez
spectaculaire des prix quand même
accru sa non plus mais madame mais bon
il faut vraiment être clair mais le
maquereau la commune son entreprise
elles payeront on à l'incurie le pays au
bord en est qu elle pouvait pas mais
elle masque rouge elles n'ont elles sont
choisies en écu les elle même s'était si
besoin
elle a donné la sienne vous l'avez
comptait céder et liara pour dû
partiellement il fait bon vivre a
répondu fondamental pour nos concitoyens
quel est votre rôle devant mais j'y
réponds parce que celle inverse de ça
mais c'est fondamental parce qu'une
grande entreprise elle ne pourra pas
payer en euros d'un côté et payer ses
salariés de l'autre en france et
n'importe quoi madame le pen les haies
ça n'a jamais existé
l'écu c'était une monnaie de référence
personne ne payait en écu notre dette
elle sera payé en euros ou en francs
c'est ça la question votre vision de
l'europe mais c'était sans parce que
c'est on a le grand n'importe quoi du
projet la bm lebel avait expliqué le
grand n'importe quoi qui mena les jeux
voir venir le projet peur le projet peur
que vous avez des
depuis le début de me fait rire ça
depuis le début moi ça me fait pas rire
les français ça les fait rire parce que
quand le vrai que abord le brésil pourra
dire ils ont fait peur on leur a dit
vous allez voir mes affaires des
fondements de l'économie britannique et
l'économie britannique ne s'est jamais
aussi bien portée que depuis que les
britanniques ont décidé de reprendre
notre libre leur liberté vis-à-vis de
l'union européenne du matin ça marchait
plus pour pablo sorin
chose la grande bretagne a n'a jamais
été dans le roman d'un sujet ça fait pas
le sujet c'est un sujet d'ordre est
toujours le même vous utilisez les mêmes
arguments vous avez dit aux britanniques
si jamais vous votez pour la sortie de
l'union européenne n'en parlons même pas
de la monnaie il n'était pas dans l'euro
si jamais vous sortez de l'union peine
vous allez voir ça va être dramatique
vous le vôtre économie va s'effondrer
vous allez entrer en récession le
chômage va exploser eh bien c'est
exactement l'inversé qui s'est déroulé
fin donc le projet qui est menée par les
puissances financières qui vous suit
jalal al hayya et to be la petite île
isolée celle ci s'était vu des questions
marine le pen a laissé des systèmes
quillan parce que c'est à leurs
bénéfices en réel même s'il vous plaît
l'euro c'est la monnaie des banquiers
que vous exprimer sur le rsa n'est pas
la monnaie du peuple
c'est la raison pour laquelle il faut
que l'on arrive à s'arracher à cette
monnaie raison mais je sais que tout le
système la défendre à monsieur macro car
ision un bénévole macron en 2022 la
france et l'europe s'est coordonné leurs
deux mois je vais vous dire je suis
contre tout ce qu'a dit madame le pen
marion alors alors allez
madame le pen d'accord on peut avoir un
débat démocratique les dialysés mal
après d'abord la grande peur qui la
manipulent depuis le début c'est vous
qui joue avec les peurs de nos
concitoyens sur le terrorisme etc c'est
vous la grande peur la grande prêtresse
de la peur elle est en face de moi la
grande bretagne ça n'a rien à voir avec
nous elle n'était pas dans l'euro elle
ne l'a jamais été donc maintenant l'euro
vous vous proposer d'en sortir moi je
dis que c'est un projet mortifère et que
c'est un projet dangereux et que votre
bidouillage que vous nous avez fait dans
le week end avec monsieur dupont-aignan
n'a aucun sens il d'ailleurs une
manifeste une impréparation crasse et
vous votre excuse ma vision c'est
justement de construire un euro fort et
de construire une politique européenne
qui sera forte et dans laquelle nous
défendrons les intérêts de la france
mais je veux que tout le monde comprenne
c'est fondamental les éleveurs du cantal
aujourd'hui il achète ses produits à
l'étranger ils les achètera donc en
euros mais il perd à ses salariés en
france
quand il un drame s'est produit ah bah
oui les produits h m s'est bien vendu
les produits phytosanitaires beaucoup et
puis s'il est éleveur il a ce qu'on
appelle des broutards ils les envoient
derrière en grèce et en italie donc les
italiens élus achèteront en euros mais
lui peyras et ses salariés en france où
l'alors pays aux abonnés mettront à
bompas que vous allez décider pour les
omanais vous allez décider pour laisser
une chance à la négociation que je vais
mener d'accord donc vous allez décider
pour les 27 pays et vous allez en
particulier pour les 19 pays de la zone
euro leur expliquer qu'ils vont sortir
avant tout pour tous ceux qui souffrent
et qui a envie de retrouver leur monnaie
nationale le désir de mourir de l'euro
ce que je suis en train de dire c'est
que tout ça ça n'existe pas deux
secondes le paysan du cantal qui
m'écoutent il a bien compris parce que
lui il vit dans l'europe celui qui fait
des pommes dans la vallée de la durance
et qui les vend aujourd'hui en euros qui
a besoin de l'euro comme monnaie commune
demain il ne l'aura plus
l'épargnant qui nous écoutent le jour
vous fait cette sortie parce que comment
vous financer votre programme vous
d'évaluer le nouveau franc de 20 à 30%
ok il perd il perd le jour d'après
grains à 30% de la valeur de son épargne
parce que tous les biens que nous
continuerons à importer du reste de la
zone euro parce que nous sommes intégrés
dans cette zone euro qu'on le veuille ou
non c'est la réalité de l'économie
française vous avez été ministre de
l'économie oui madame le pen vous dites
ça oui madame le père ferries p&o nom
est d'accord c'est parce que c'est la
vérité comme assez inquiétant mais non
c'est par exemple on ne vous inquiétez
pas chers français comprenez pourquoi
les résultats ont été si mauvais le pen
énormités et le vrai vous avez le temps
de vous exprimer bon d'accord je veux de
téléphone portable peut-être même vos
dossiers ils sont faits aujourd'hui dans
des pays aussi qu'ils sont étrangers et
même ce qui est fait en france a besoin
du reste de l'europe quand celles et
ceux qui nous écoutent à toulouse ou à
saint nazaire où dans beaucoup d'autres
endroits en france travaillent sur
l'a320 il ya plus de 150000 françaises
et français qui travaillent sur ce
projet airbus comme ses sous traitants
il ya un tiers de la valeur qui est fait
dans d'autres pays européens parce que
nous sommes intégrés et bien le jour
d'après comme vous avez renchérir le
bien de ce qui est fait en allemagne ou
ailleurs parce qu'il sera toujours en
euros lui eu égard dron l'euro nous on
sera en francs mais vous allez baisser
leur compétitivité nous sommes donc nous
allons gagner de lacombe nous allons
assurément parce que ça non le mark je
vous ai apprécié je veux justement c'est
l'allemagne qui va beaucoup d'aller à
dame le pen je vous ai je vous dis
appelé cama touazi expliqué développer
votre argument avec beaucoup de détails
pour pouvoir justement maintenant
expliquer à la fois terminée terme et
l'inanité et demi mais pour ce que je
vous dis juste que la france les mains
et votre hymne à la france ça n'est pas
un pays fermé c'est un pays qui est dans
l'europe et dans le monde la question ce
n'est pas l'esprit de défaites que vous
voulez c'est le candidat de l'ouverture
vers non je suis le candidat d'une
france forte dans une europe qui protège
mais je ne veux pas pour nos concitoyens
qu'ils perdent du pouvoir d'achat des
emplois de la compétitivité par la
sortie de l'euro c'est ce que vous
proposez elle protège les donc je vais
jusqu'au bout on a les éléments ya mieux
n'oserait j'ai je vous ai avec
courtoisie laisser faire et donc je dis
que votre projet il est mortifère sur le
plan du pouvoir d'achat sur le plan de
la compétitivité et de notre capacité à
être fort dans le monde moi ce que je
veux c'est une france qui fait les
réformes qui prend ses responsabilités
c'est ce que j'expliquais tout à l'heure
sur le plan du chômage de la formation
professionnelle parce que il ya beaucoup
de pays qui s'en sortent très bien dans
l'euro et c'est votre campagne c'est
votre problème allemand prenez-en même
de nombreux autres l'alma et ils ont
fait des réformes ils ont fait des
réformes madame le pen il ya des pays
qui vont mal hors de l'euro est ce que
vous proposez c'est la guerre des
monnaies on l'a connu pendant des années
et des années ça ne nous a pas aidés et
ça nous a pas sortie du chômage de marne
avait quand même beaucoup de choses
aujourd'hui quand même non madame le pen
ah bon dans les années 90 où dans les
années 2000 cas eva - chômeurs qu'on a
fait on avait vous savez plus de
chômeurs qu'aujourd'hui même plus que
l'on se meurt quand j'en ai il ya aussi
des cycles économiques et les réformes
n'ont pas été faites comme elles
devaient non plus au début des années
2000 c'est tout donc en demi il y avait
plus de chômeurs aujourd'hui madame le
pen je vous avez été ministre de
l'économie a fait que par mois non moi
je n'y connais rien mais vous avez été
ministre de l'économie quoi madame
musicaux n'est sûr sûrement mais
heureuse vous savez quoi le pen
heureusement parce que ce que vous
proposez heureusement qu'il ya des
internautes qui vont tout de suite
regardé s'il y avait plus de chemin on
en 2000 que aujourd'hui j'ai dit j'ai
dit au début des années 90 quand il y
avait la guerre des monnaies mais non
madame le pen moi je suis prêt si on
travaille voilà vous étiez de madrid où
il pas à couper donc au début des années
90 quand il y avait la vraie guerre des
monnaies et que la france n'était pas
encore rentré dans une convergence en
particulier avec l'allemagne il y avait
plus de chômeurs qu'aujourd'hui la
france ne se porte pas mieux donc le
projet qui est le mien c'est d'avoir une
france qui est compétitive c'est pas
l'esprit de défaite de madame le pen
c'est de rester dans l'euro parce qu'il
nous protège l'euro il évite les
déstabilisations monétaire c'est
protéger l'épargné de nos concitoyens
parce que j'y tiens et moi je ne veux
pas d'un comportement de panique le
projet de madame le pen le jour d'après
il faudra restaurer le contrôle des
capitaux vous l'avez d'ailleurs avoué
vous même dans une interview récente je
ne veux pas du contrôle de capitaux ce
sera la panique bancaire et le projet
c'est l'affaiblissement notre industrie
et moi je veux dans cette europe dès le
début
profondément changé la directive
travailleurs détachés en tant que
ministre moi j'ai pas fais simplement
des mots sur des rapides mamanana s'est
instauré la carte de contrôle dans le
btp sur les travailleurs détachés parce
que c'est comme ça qu'on lutte contre le
travail des tâches est illégal ce que je
veux c'est qu'aujourd'hui pour le même
travail dans un pays qui est le même
salaire ça on peut le faire par une
révision de la directive c'est le début
je veux que deuxième chose sont les
charges qui sont pas les mêmes non
salaire complet madame le pen charges
comprises deuxième chose je veux vous
avez imposé ça aussi l'appareil
une négociation n'était pas possible
vous savez les négociations sont
possibles j'étais ministre j'ai lutté
contre le dumping des chinois dans
l'espace n'a pas bien marché quand même
et ça l'a stoppé avec moi c'est pas des
grandes paroles et moi je ne propose pas
le grand n'importe quoi on va vous
regarder en arrivant avec des yeux
honnêtement et tenez donc ce que je
propose c'est clair c'est cohérent c'est
d'avoir une europe qui protège davantage
avec des marchés européens qui perdent
qui sont réservées à au moins 50 % des
entreprises européennes un euro fort
avec plus d'investissement européen
parce que nous en avons besoin avoir un
vrai contrôle et donc un travail
détachées qui est mieux contrôler
qu'aujourd'hui et enfin c'est d'avoir
une politique commerciale qui protège
plus qu'aujourd'hui on a besoin d'une
politique commerciale européenne
pourquoi parce que c'est celle qui
protège par rapport à la chine à la
russie ou à d'autres grands pays parce
qu'aujourd'hui nous avons un marché de
60 millions d'habitants et la chine à
plus d'un milliard une politique
commerciale qui ne seraient que
française ne protégera pas les intérêts
de la france s'il veut croire conditions
les faits au niveau européen comme moi
je les fais sur la sidérurgie et les
salariés les ouvriers de la sidérurgie
le savent on a pu stopper les attaques
chinoises parce qu'on a une politique
européenne qui s'est réveillée moi je
veux une europe qui va plus vite une
europe qui protège qui est moins
bureaucrates nakouh mais on a besoin de
l'europe dans la mondialisation ça fait
25 ans que vous promettez l'europe
sociale vous et vos amis socialistes
madame le 25 ans fait pas 25 ans nous
avons juste une biche de la
désindustrialisation massive
nous avons subi l'effondrement de nos
ampoules de nos emplois et les
délocalisations
massives et aujourd'hui parce que les
deux camps n'ont pas été les dignes des
fans et 100 euros cela les programmes
les élèves français est en danger à
cause de la pose de votre projet à cause
de l'europe la cocarde d'or mais c'est
très important de ceux qui nous écoutent
mof comprendre si l'état stratège que je
mènerai n'est pas là pour taper du poing
sur la table et pour empêcher la loi sur
l'union bancaire qui en cas de
défaillance bancaire ira piocher
directement dans les comptes en banque
des épargnants un signe dans la leur
assurance vie c'est d'ailleurs ce qu'ils
ont fait à chypre si ce n'est pas moi
qui avec l'état stratège dit non je
protègerai l'épargné des français quel
qu'en soit le prix et quelle que soit la
bagarre que je dois mener avec l'union
européenne alors les français se feront
ponctionner leur épargne donc le grand
danger aujourd'hui monsieur macro et
c'est la soumission arts à l'union
européenne madame le problème monsieur
macron des paniques bancaires quand elle
a eu lieu à chypre vous êtes arrivé à
athènes c'était quoi la menace et moi
par les ménages et la sortie et man pour
moi ces actions sont battus pour rester
dans l'euro parce qu'ils lisent rection
monsieur macron m'est arrivé c'est que
vous êtes allé voir madame merkel et
vous êtes allé lui demander sa
bénédiction car vous n'envisagez de ne
rien faire sans avoir l'accord de madame
merkel c'est si vrai que quand on vous a
dit mais comment vous allez faire face à
madame merkel vous avez dit mais je
serai pas face à elle je serai avec elle
donc bien sûr que oui non une france qui
se faisaient passer monsieur macron de
toute façon la france sera dirigée par
une femme ce sera au mois ou madame
d'accord alors elle est là la réalité
arrêtée bien évidemment comme une
formule ligne actuelle et lala
heureusement notre musique a eu des
dirigeants visuel vous laisser le madame
le maire est interrompue non mais non
c'est moi qui bien eu des dirigeants
visionnaires le général de gaulle et le
chancelier adenauer ils ont su
travailler ensemble ils l'ont fait le
avec il voulait plus notre époque il ne
devançait fair play et ils ont construit
cette europe n'est pas celle d'être une
a bien compris motivé il ya le régime
par le dr jean certains j'ai eu
l'occasion de voyages je viens d'une
région qui a connu dans sa chair la
guerre moi ma famille elle l'a connu je
ne veux pas du nationalisme que vous
portez un projet que vous portez ça il
fallait que le pelage et c'était bien
procès vous avez aimé parce que vous
êtes passé par des bières mais pas
vraiment là vous pouvez rigoler moi je
n'en connais pas je savais que vous
alliez me laisse assez colle pas avec ça
je me pose est de savoir à quel moment
vous allez le protectionnisme
l'isolationnisme le nationalisme c'est
votre projet on a créé le repli et la
guerre avec l'autre on l'a connu pendant
des siècles et des siècles et des gens
qui ont payé vous vous trompez mais la
ville historique mais bien sûr c'est ce
que c'est vrai que l'histoire de france
vous intéresse pas elle impute la
culture de français maths hélas comme la
culture jeu vous intéresse la réalité
n'avons pas la même veine mais je vous
le confirme c'est que c'est le désert
réalité c'est que ce que vous proposez
c'est une sortie de l'histoire c'est le
désir que nos concitoyens mais c'est le
déséquilibre dans les rapports entre
l'allemagne et la france qui sont en
réalité les germes de la guerre quand
les rapports sont équilibrés quand
chacun défend ses intérêts quand on
n'est pas soumis inféodé aux exigences
de l'allemagne alors les choses si tout
cela c'est la guerre elle a été créée
par cette soumission monsieur m'a
conseils que vous êtes en train de
reproduire car vous êtes la france
soumise à la lnah attendait mais vous
vous dirigez une soumission économique à
la
et c'est extrêmement long moment là et
losc ne seront pas laissés s'est bien
portée il s'agit de notre souveraineté
il s'agit de notre indépendance mais il
s'agit aussi de la défendre les intérêts
des français mais on a parfaitement
contrat les allemands parfaitement
vous avez de vieux bon vous avez deux
visions irréconciliables
a compris cela pour l'art c'est vrai
qu'on attend que nos concitoyens à
protéger les allemands sont sidérés en
consignant madame leclerc d'allemagne 60
comprimés le plein accord était avec
de l'allemagne n'a jamais fait
progresser la moi je comprends leur
intérêt à y répondre une réunion n'aura
droit qu'à des mais vous vous délectez
les rieurs la télé remontée les cds
éventuellement revu les intérêts de la
france ne s'allieront pas s'il vous
plaît
notre vraie galette avec la chine l etat
et les btp élargir le périmètre alors
gérard le régulièrement dit suffisamment
que c'est le parent pauvre des débats la
politique étrangère alors on voudrait
juste avoir une précision de votre côté
puisque c'est une des prérogatives du
chef de l'état qu'elle doive être la
nature des relations que nous devrons
avoir d'abord à musique monsieur trump
ensuite avec monsieur poutine je vous
demande de répondre emmanuel macron vous
avez une minute vingt de retard je sais
trump monsieur poutine quelle est la
nature des relations entre la france et
moi la ligne que je veux avoir pour la
france c'est une ligne que je
qualifierais de golaud mitterrandienne
c'est l'indépendance de la france c'est
pour ça que je veux une france forte
qu'ils fassent ces réformes qui soit
crédible et qui soit forte en europe
parce que notre monde est de plus en
plus déstabilisé il est déstabilisé sur
le plan économique avec une guerre sans
merci il est déstabilisé sur le plan de
notre sécurité internationale parce que
le terrorisme se joue hors de nos
frontières aussi dans la zone irako
syrienne en libye dans la zone sahélo
saharienne et parce qu'il est
déstabilisé par une recomposition des
alliances dans ce contexte là je veux
une france qui sache construire la paix
ma priorité en terme de politique
étrangère ce sera la lutte contre le
terrorisme islamiste en continuant le
travail dans les alliances et à ce titre
je proposerai à monsieur trump de
continuer le travail avec les états unis
d'amérique qui sont nos partenaires en
termes de renseignements qui sont nos
partenaires
autour de la table du conseil de
sécurité des nations unies nous en avons
besoin et je souhaite que nous
continuons ce travail parce que nous
avons depuis la seconde guerre mondiale
et même avant était dans le même camp
classiquement avec notre voix
indépendantes et je m'en félicite et je
porterai cette même voie par exemple
lorsque la france a refusé d'accompagner
le conflit en irak mais nous avons
besoin d'avoir cette coopération forte
pour notre sécurité je veux aussi
poursuivre avec monsieur trump le
travail qui a été commencé sur le climat
nous avons besoin d'une vraie politique
a pas le même avis manifestement non
mais je lui propose de le faire parce
que sa société civile n'a pas le même
avis que lui parce qu'il va vite
comprendre que ce n'est pas son intérêt
est donc je proposerai à monsieur trump
de continuer le travail ensemble et sur
le plan économique
je veux une europe justement plus forte
parce que si nous voulons être crédibles
face aux états unis d'amérique on a
besoin d'avoir un marché européen
intégré efforts pour nous protéger c'est
le sens des réformes que je porte avec
un vrai marché européen et en
particulier une vraie politique de
marchés publics et d'achats européens
quant à monsieur poutine il est autour
de la table sur plusieurs sujets de
discussion le confluent craignant il
faut désescalade et ce conflit il faut
progressivement normalisée mais il faut
qu'il respecte le processus en cours et
le conflit en syrie où là il doit être
autour de la table il est un des
éléments de la réponse mais en aucun cas
je ne serai soumis au diktat de monsieur
poutine c'est ma grande différence avec
le projet de madame le pen qui est là
dans un vrai projet de soumission à
l'égard de monsieur poutine et de la
russie soumission financières allemandes
on le sait et soumission à l'égard des
valeurs qu'il porte qui ne sont pas les
nôtres il n'a rien demandé alors les
nôtres et donc sur le sujet sur le sujet
si rien je veux en la matière que notre
priorité soit la lutte contre le
djihadisme terroriste qui sévit dans la
région et je veux au-delà de tous qu'on
arrive à trouver une solution politique
négociée en mettant toutes les parties
prenantes autour de la table donc ce
sera un partenaire de travail sur
quelques problématiques régionales avec
lequel je discuterai mais en ayant
conscience que nous n'avons sur beaucoup
de sujets pas les mêmes valeurs et les
mêmes priorités marine le pen donald
trump l'admirent poutine vous savez je
crois que c'est serait intéressant ce
que vous avez monsieur malgré ce qu'en
fait on voit toute la différence qu'il
ya entre la vision qui est la vôtre et
celle qui est la mienne vous avez parlé
de la france en faisant la france sera
respectée si elle est une grande
puissance économique etc ça y est on
revient au gras fier politique du jihad
dans la france soit respectée si elle
est la france si elle redevient
véritablement la france avec cette voix
particulière qu'elle avait dans le monde
parce que le monde attend la france et
la france a perdu cette voie
particulière parce qu'elle s'est soumise
précisément à l'allemagne elle s'est
soumise à la politique américaine elle
doit donc retrouver son indépendance ce
que je suis désolé de vous le rappeler
mais le général de gaulle avait imposé à
de multiples reprises
l'indépendance de la voix de la france
dans le monde et pour obtenir son
indépendance il faut qu'elle n'est pas
ou qu'elles ne se soumettent pas à la
vision un père ali impérialiste des uns
ou des autres oui vous est donc parce
que ça aussi ça crée la guerre c'est en
réalité ça qui crée la guerre vous avez
bien compris c'est parce que le
contraire de l'impérialisme c'est le
fait de respecter toutes les nations et
moi je crois qu'il faut que la france
soit à nouveau le
l'état qui soient
respectueux de toutes les nations ça
veut dire respectueux de leur identité
ça veut dire respectueux de leur culture
ça veut dire respectueux de leurs
systèmes d'organisation politique aussi
la moralisation les leçons morales que
vous d'ailleurs donné toujours mais
seuls les socialistes c'est une grande
spécialité de l'inde et son moral vous
donner des leçons de morale à la terre
entière fap à la terre entière ça aussi
ça le problème c'est que c'est toujours
deux poids deux mesures il y a ce qui
voudrait descendre morale là vous
répétez monsieur poutine sinon on a
confiance il ya ceux qui sont vos atouts
vraiment un gars d oman au qatar par
exemple la saudi à qui vous ne donnez
pas de leçons à madame le pen cherche et
que j'allais deuxième fois parce que là
vous faites un grand gagner arrêtez de
me couper la parole de la parole parce
que vous dites est vital mais vous ne me
prenez c'est pas grave visuel dans tout
à l'heure de rideau le pen je suis très
calme c'est moi terminer les choses
d'abord soyez courtois vous ne répondez
pas aux questions qui vous sont des
cours sur la forme de courtoisie aussi
le qatar l'arabie saoudite c'est dans
mon projet je propose de 3g de vie des
deux journalistes je crois aux affaires
le produire et attendait n'est qu'alors
que faudra-t-il au journal je propose de
supprimer la convention fiscale dont
l'un d'eux dit pas de mensonge est une
fois encore voulaient pas leur établir
une liste et parce que je n'étais pas en
charge la norme allianz arena ont
pardonnés s'ils avaient à peine mais je
serai président y aura dix jours dans
des compétences et font pas tout et
n'importe quoi votre relation mais mal à
dormir prestige et moi mais je vais
attendre juste de pouvoir m'exprimer
parce que bon c'est aussi votre le
premier depuis tout à l'heure vous savez
quand on rêve l'euro vous étiez dans la
grande province si ça va mieux bon et
moi ça je dirais madaghri peine un mois
je pense que nous devons être à
équidistance net de la russie et des
états unis nous n'avons aucune raison de
mener une guerre froide a réussi nous
avons toutes les raisons d'engager avec
la réussite des relations que sur des
relations diplomatiques commerciales
stratégiques parce que c est une grande
nation et que la russie n'a pas exprimé
d'hostilité à l'égard de la france
encore une fois moi je me moque de
savoir quelles sont les relations entre
les etats-unis et la russie jeu j'espère
qu'elles seront les meilleurs du monde
et je vais vous dire je pense que dans
ce monde qui est en train de changer
monsieur macro qui est en train de faire
des choix qui sont exactement l'inversé
des vôtres en réalité est en train de
défendre leur indépendance une forme de
protectionnisme intelligent qui tourne
le dos à l'ingérence systématique et
bien je suis la mieux parler paul la
mieux placée pour parler à ce monde-là
la mieux placée pour parler à l'âne de
moody pourparlers à la réussite poutine
pour parler aux états unis de train pour
parler à la grande bretagne de theresa
may mais c'est là après vous même et eu
des propos très amènes à l'égard des
des états-unis de la russie vous avez
réussi à vous fâcher avec tout le monde
à donner des leçons de morale à tout le
monde moi je crois que ça n'est pas la
manière de faire de la diplomatie d'être
entendue dans le monde si nous ne
retrouvons pas notre place diplomatiques
avec cette voix qui est la voie de
l'indépendance qui est la voix de la
souveraineté qui est la voix encore une
fois de la défense des peuples alors la
france ne fera pas son grand retour dans
le monde et elle continuera à être
regardé il faut bien le dire comme
madame merkel nous regarde depuis déjà
des années va changer de thématiques
dans les deux cinémas y être élu ouais
le monde ne nous regarderait pas d'une
belle manière on va jouer les grandes
nations et regarder l'écran lorsque l'un
d'eux la russie les a bien de finir la
presse internationale pense que l'image
que vous donnez de la france je pense qu
avec les affaires toutes ces
illustrations dont parle la presse
internationale je pourrais même pas une
belle image que tout est devant lui ne
verra leur victoire 8 mai on verra la
tuile mais couple sur la ligne que je
porte ont tourné le dos aux vieilles
badernes de l'ultra tous les ultra
libéralisme que vous continuez à
défendre
il est vrai change intégral fait tout ça
s'est fait
élire avec vous que vos vieilles vos
vieux modèle économique des années 90
beaucoup y avait également fermé à
l'époque il y avait même thatcher par
l'école ça ne vous
ni laisser personne ne plus personne
nous étions l'admiration devant ce livre
dont on enfin l'avenir
ce sera le peuple français
le peuple français s'il vous plaît s'il
vous plaît on change de thématiques
pourquoi je connaissais déjà dans mes
choix c'est bien mais je dis juste nommé
non mais vous êtes tellement arrogants
vous avez déjà fêté votre victoire à la
rotonde avant même madame avant la fin
du second tour bon oeil et regarde
m'arrivent numérisés encore ça leur
donnait français nous regarde attendez
les français ne nous regardent ils ont
envie de savoir exactement quel est
votre projet pour l'école loyer mes
questions sont courtes j'espère que les
rib ou répondent se seront au maximum et
macron c'est à vous mon projet pour
l'école c'est de concentrer les moyens
sur l'école primaire on a aujourd'hui 20
% des élèves qui ne savent pas bien lire
écrire ou compter en cm2 ce sont les
élèves qui vont être en échec scolaire
au collège et qu'on va retrouver dans
ces cent à cent cinquante mille jeunes
qui sortent du système scolaire à l'âge
de 18 ans et qui n'ont ni emploi
l'information la mère des batailles
c'est l'école primaire et donc je la
porterai de plusieurs manières d'abord
en rétablissant les heures
d'enseignement dont le français qui ont
été retirées ces dernières années en
rétablissant les classes bilangues
l'enseignement du latin au collège
les travaux dirigés essentiel parce que
dans une famille nombreuse une famille
modeste et bien les inégalités de ce
retrait quand on revient à la maison et
donc le travail dirigé est essentiel et
dans ces zones d'éducation prioritaire
où la pauvreté les problèmes se
concentrent je veux qu'on réduise le
nombre d'élèves par classe en cp ce1
parce que c'est là qu'on fait
l'apprentissage de la langue et des
fondamentaux et donc on ramènera à douze
élèves par classe ce sont douze mille
classes donc 12000 postes d'enseignants
pour partie en redéployant pour partie
en les embauchant c'est indispensable
ensuite ya l'effort en matière
d'orientation que je veux faire à la fin
du collège comme à la fin du lycée où on
doit mettre davantage les entreprises
les formations universitaires ce qu'on
appelle le post baccalauréat présents
dans l'entreprise pour expliquer quels
sont les débouchés parce qu'aujourd'hui
les jeunes de milieux modestes ou dans
les parents n'ont pas réussi forcément
dans la société ils ont un diplôme le
baccalauréat et ils sont aujourd'hui mal
orienté ne savent pas vers où aller
c'est aussi le sens de la réforme que je
veux mener
pour l'université en mettant de la
transparence sur les résultats des
filières universitaires pour que quand
on va s'inscrire dans une formation on
sache le nombre de jeunes qu'il a fini
ce que donne le diplôme et si on a un
emploi à la clé et le dernier point
c'est de développer l'apprentissage
parce que beaucoup de nos jeunes ne vont
pas réussir à travers des formations
académiques et pour qu'ils aient un
emploi une place dans la société
l'apprentissage est indispensable y font
à simplifier les règles il faut le
rapprocher de celles et ceux qui
embauchent c'est à dire les branches
professionnelles pour définir les
formations et l'organisation s'est
rapidement brossé le projet que j'ai
pour l'école et la formation de nos
jeunes bien qui est le premier chantier
pour moi de la reconstruction du pays et
d'être la transformation que je veux
mener merci pour votre réponse marine le
pen votre école ressemble à quoi nicole
elle a été saccagé par les socialistes
il faut quand même le dire saccagés on a
fait n'importe quoi
on a au lieu d'apprendre le français et
réservé comme je le souhaite 50% de
l'apprentissage en primaire à la langue
française parce que c'est la base de
tout et de manière générale aux savoirs
fondamentaux on a mis en place des
apprentissages pour les enfants de leur
langue d'origine on a réduit
l'enseignement de la grammaire on a
supprimé le redoublement parce qu'en
fait c'étaient des considérations
budgétaires c'était pas le bien-être des
enfants c'était pour faire des économies
on a demandé aux élèves de construire
leurs savoirs sais pas ce que ça voulait
dire mes enfants mon bref on a effondré
l'autorité du maître donc il faut
revenir à une école qui transmet et une
école qui transmet dans
la discipline c'est à dire le retour
encore une fois de l'autorité nécessaire
du maître et du respect du maître il
faut aussi valoriser considérablement
les filières professionnelles parce que
là encore
les symptômes de bobos ont considéré
qu'il fallait que tout le monde ait bac
+ 12 et que tous ceux qui travaillent
avec leurs mains étaient des gens qui
n'étaient même pas consister pour la fin
du collège gambetta rue madame najat
vallaud belkacem me parler de tri
sélectif quand je parlais de filières
professionnelles à elle vous soutient
aussi tiens vous saviez non mais sa vie
est beaucoup de gens qui le soutiennent
et à mon programme le pen beaucoup
ministre beaucoup de ministres est
beaucoup de socialiser à robersart
combien d'ailleurs vous alertant de
marine le pen vous êtes glace alors vous
êtes élu cette fois la fin du collège
donc la vie poursuit marie le pen et
donc les sept filières professionnelles
il faut évidemment qu on la développe et
qu'on la valorise parce que cela fait
maintenant des années et des années que
on
laisse penser à nos jeunes que avec bac
+5 et bien ils auront un emploi alors
que de plus en plus vous le savez ça
n'est pas le cas je veux qu'à
l'université et le critère
soit le mérite et ne soit pas le tirage
au sort comme les socialistes viennent
de décider ce que je trouve le plus
injuste en réalité un la sélection
aujourd'hui à se fait soit par l'échec
soit par le tirage au sort bon c'est
absolument inouïe il faut qu'elle se
refasse à nouveau mérite et je souhaite
au passage que dans l'université la
laïcité s'applique puisque je crois que
vous êtes pour le voile à l'université
moi je suis très opposé évidemment voile
à l'université comme je suis très opposé
à tous les signes ostensibles dans
l'espace public ainsi que dans
l'entreprise je pense qu'aujourd'hui
compte tenu de la situation la laïcité
doit s'imposer partout bien entendu à
l'école avec la neutralité dont on parle
souvent on n'en a pas contre moi par
aussi importante mais aussi dans
l'ensemble de la cité de l'espace public
voilà aujourd'hui très honnêtement il
est vrai que plus le niveau
d'enseignement est bas et plus il y à
une sélection par l'argent et par la
naissance quand on apprend plus rien ce
qui fait la différence à la fin novembre
ce sont les relations chesnais l'argent
arrive ça c'est tout à fait contraire
chez régalerez pu voir chez les non pas
qu'on veuille vous couper la parole mais
vous avez tout dit souhaiter que le
débat dure pas le débat ne dure pas
quatre heures qu'ils soient dans une
limite 2h à 2h30 on vous posez la
question suivante et je vais vous
demander une réponse assez brève
concernant les institutions le
fonctionnement la république les bras
est ce que vous considérez qu'il faut
baisser le nombre de parlementaires et
que pensez-vous du cumul des mandats ce
que vous êtes prêts les limites et de
quelle façon emmanuel macron s'il vous
plaît vous êtes légère morte à une
réponse s'il vous plaît brève pour qu'on
puisse avancer en quoi oui aux deux
questions je suis favorable à une baisse
du nombre de parlementaires les ramener
les baisser d'environ un tiers à
l'assemblée comme au sénat je souhaite
d'ailleurs pouvoir conduire cette
réforme de manière rapide dans un ordre
différent du quinquennat non il faut une
réforme qui a des contraintes
constitutionnelles comme vous le savez
et je n'exclus pas d'ailleurs des deux
ans le peuple s'il y avait un blocage
des assemblées en léger retrait pardon
un référendum donc donc je souhaite
réduire d'un tiers le nombre de
parlementaires je souhaite instaurer
également une dose de proportionnelle
pour les élections y compris les
élections parlementaires ce ne sera pas
possible pour celles qui arrivent par
définition mais je souhaite que les
choses soient claires au moment de cette
élection pour la suite parce que je
pense que ça permet de mieux représenter
toutes les forces sur le cumul sur le
cumul des mandats je suis évidemment
favorable au maintien de la loi qui a
été votée durant ce quinquennat qui
empêche le cumul de plusieurs mandats
concomitants aidant les gens veut
ajouter à cela un non cumul des mandats
dans le temps limiter à trois mandats
madame le pen vous allez l'appliquer à
ce que vous allez investir là je vais
appliquer la libération c'est ma grande
différence est donc sûre sur la
partition années candidat vous allez
voir comment ça va se passer parce que
voir même faire quelque chose qui va
beaucoup vous embarrasser c'est que non
seulement j'aurais la moitié de
candidats nouveau mais aucun aura un
casier judiciaire southend inéligible
existe chez nous depuis 20 ans jean
madame le pen parce que vous voyez il
avait inventé l'eau chaude en
l'occurrence non mais vous savez le
parti des affaires nouvelles a le milan
c'est le vol investi le parti qu'il va
pas devant les juges c'est le vaut pas
le mien partie de la refaire vous voyez
soyez oui c'est la richesse que vous
dites monsieur laval madame le pen
j'espère qu'on n'apprendra rien dans les
quelques jours ou quelques semaines
parce qu'on vous savez les leçons on
vous savez combien de chercher par sanaa
y compris vos amis beaucoup
idéal c'est bon je peux pas les imac or
personne n'a compris les explications
que vous aviez donné sur votre
patrimoine en l'occurrence le fils de
jacques voudraient ils assurent le vôtre
il l'a envoyé aussitôt le président de
la haute autorité qui est un ami de
monsieur hollande l'a renvoyée au génie
zaki a appelé à voter pour lui en 2012
mais il ya là encore une pétition qui
circule de professeur d'université
d'avocats qui vous demandent des
explications sur 15 points qui ont été
qui comprennent pas comment ils vont
vous avez réussi à décoller à la dame le
plasma par jour et madame le pen c'est
pas grave
c'est vrai pour que je sais que la
france qui entre vous et moi c'est que
vous êtes vous sous le coup d'une
procédure judiciaire que la haute
autorité qui a regardé mon dossier qui a
vu qu'il n'y avait pas de problème à
regardiez les vins la mine monsieur non
c'était indépendante ce sont nos
institutions comme les juges vous vous
remettez en quand les juges ne nous
arrange pas vous dites qu'ils ne sont
pas honnêtes car l'institution
judiciaire à l'export dans notre pays
mais oui madame le pen ne plaisantait
pas avec ça l'institution judiciaire
qu'on apprendra madame vous avez un
compte offshore aux bahamas ou chez
pages denses à rien avec le pen ça c'est
de la diffamation alors j'espère vous on
sait en tout cas ce que vous avez un
patrimoine qui est sous-évaluée et vous
on sait en tout cas que vous êtes là
sous le cas d'une procédure judiciaire
ce n'est pas mon cas c'est la grande
différence câble faisais moi votre vous
avez des
mois je n'en ai pas valablement pour sa
création ce qui nous différencie vous
pouvez que vous ne cessez de me couper
la main monsieur mal main madame le pen
l'un ou l'autre d'entre nous devra être
le garant de nos institutions nous
aspirons à cela vous avez menacé les
fonctionnaires vous dites en permanence
du mal des juges dès qu'il ne vous
arrange pas vous n'êtes par ses propos
pas digne d'être garant demain des
institutions parce que vous les menaces
et c'est cela votre problème et ce
problème ou superviser votre problème à
vous c'est que vous êtes en conflit
d'intérêts permanent madame levée d'un
conflit d'intérêt permanent et moi
figurez vous je serai la meilleure
garante des institutions parce que je
les connais bien j'ai été avocat pendant
un certain nombre d'années figurez vous
oui je connais très bien comment
fonctionne toute la justice et je
connais très bien la manière dont
parfois des fonctionnaires on leur
demande des choses qui ne sont pas
admissibles et ils sont parfois obligés
de le faire c'est malheureux et c'est de
ça dont je veux les protéger c'est de l'
influence du pouvoir politique sur leur
indépendance et sur la manière dont il
respecte la loi voyez vous il ya les
gars se connaît très très bien tout ce
qui se passe et comment ça se passe
croyez moi hein je vous expliquerai vous
viendrez me voir mais je dire exactement
quand madame le pen mais ça c'est pour
le référé de
cet arrêt juste pouvoir
minutes je n'irai pas vous voir pour
obtenir cette île où je peux pas bien
nos concitoyens n'ont plus qu'à deux
minutes de retard par rapport à nos
concitoyens non plus alors venez encore
de montrer à quel point vous êtes
indigne en insinuant que nos juges ne
sont pas indépendants je le regrette
madame le pen la france mérite mieux que
vous nos juges à nos juges sur
indépendant globalement les jules afonso
stamile indépendant les juges du
syndicat de la magistrature comme le
fait monsieur ceux qui ont épinglé des
responsables politiques et des parents
de victimes sur un mur des cons cela
monsieur non ils sont politisées parle
pas des noms mais moi je vous en parle
monsieur il y à des magistrats qui sont
politisés cette situation est
inadmissible mais ça vous arrange parce
qu'ils sont politisés de votre côté le
fait mais ça c'est absolument pas noté
pas à votre avis personnel c'est oui nos
institutions et ses savants aller
soumettez-vous mairie vous mettez le
clou je ne me suis jamais à personne
vous êtes à plat ventre en birman en jeu
devant l'allemagne devant syndicat de la
magistrature devant lui au fief devant
les communautaristes suis dedans des
puissances d'argent aux différents les
banques à plat ventre et madame le guide
a rappelé avant je suis debout mais pour
être debout je n'ai pas besoin de salir
vous ma permanence vous salissez
représenter leur effet tranché vous
salissez les juges comme on vient de le
voir vous salissez les uns et les autres
madame le pen notre pays n'a pas besoin
de ça il a besoin d'apaisement et
d'efficacité les regrets les autres je
le regrette les dires des tripes vous
voulez dire les ouvrières de gad que
vous avez traité dit les et vous voulez
dire les chômeurs que vous avez envoyé
acheter un costard vous voulez dire
laissez-vous les habitants du nord que
vous avez traiter d'alcoolique les
harkis et les rapatrier un du nord avait
crié du traité de criminel hier de gaga
est d'ailleurs suis allé les voir et
d'ailleurs eu de chacun de ce que tout
ça c'est ce qu'ont d'ailleurs les 9 km
et d'ailleurs les neuf millions
d'électeurs les miens et ceux de nicolas
dupont aignan que vous avez tenté de
salir pendant tout ce second tour de
monde chez makro madame le pen ça on a
ça en fait des millions de français et
françaises et vous avez prises et qui
ont voté pendant toute cette campagne
j'avais des mots injurieux vaut les
françaises et les français qui ont voté
pour vous comme pour monsieur
dupont-aignan je les ai toujours
respectés je n'ai jamais fait de leçons
morales mais je les connais aussi j'en
ai dans ma région je dis juste vous dise
il était juste une chose regardez les
ils sont là ils sont dans les campagnes
dans les vies parler de photos sur les
réseaux sociaux je parle du parti de
l'ex 13 ans à 10 heures celui que vous
dirigez saint-cloud pas parti de
l'extrême droite est inquiétant qui dit
des mensonges sur les réseaux sociaux
qui poussent à la haine qui molestent
des journalistes qui prodigue partout un
traitement la grande brutalité journal
mais oui madame le pen regarder cette
campagne si j'avais mollet fait vivre
qui est venu à plusieurs reprises devant
les rassemblements publics menacé et
frappé je les ai vécus madame le pen
c'est la vérité donc c'est le parti du
front national votre parti qui est un
parti d'extrême droite qui ne ressemble
pas à notre pays qui ne ressemble pas à
notre france mais tous vos électeurs je
les respecte et je te le dis je les
respecte parce que ils sont en colère
parce qu'ils sont en désarroi parce que
je les connais je viens d'une ville qui
a aussi voté pour vous mais il ne mérite
pas votre colère vous n'apportez pas de
réponse votre collège leur colère vous
l'attisé encore vous la manipuler mais
madame le pen c'est tout ce que je dis
plus rien m'arriver pas comprendre vos
propos ne voulait pas sont plus que vous
proposez pas c'est que c'est tout ce que
je sais ils méritent mieux que ça ok
merci marie le pen email macron jeu vous
proposera bientôt conclure c'est le
temps de votre carte blanche je l'avais
souhaité l'un et l'autre vous adresser
aux français sur un thème de votre choix
vous avez deux minutes et on va
commencer par mails vaincrons vous avez
une itt de retard pour le moment c'est à
vous de commencer sur la carte blanche
on a parlé de beaucoup de sujets il y en
a évidemment qu'on n'a pas traité je ne
pourrais pas ici tous les couvrir j'ai
évoqué rapidement l'outre-mer qui est je
crois un sujet essentiel parce que nos
territoires ultramarins sont à mes yeux
un enjeu décisif notre la réussite de la
réussite économique en matière de
sécurité d'aménagement du territoire il
ya un mot que je voudrais avoir c'est
sur les personnes vivant en situation de
handicap dans notre pays parce que nous
n'en avons pas parlé pour la santé
d'abord parce que la loi que madame le
pen veut supprimer elle propose des
solutions pragmatiques pour les
personnes qui vivent en situation de
handicap dans l'entreprise cette fameuse
loi travail elle a proposé de manière
très pragmatique et je maintiendrai
cette disposition c'est d'avoir dans
l'entreprise quelqu'un qui vous aident à
pouvoir intégrer une vie normale dans
l'entreprise qui n'est pas le cas
aujourd'hui moi je veux pour toutes
celles et ceux qui vivent en situation
de handicap avoir des réponses
pragmatiques la première c'est que je
revaloriserait l'allocation adulte
handicapé qui aujourd'hui sous le seuil
de pauvreté et qui le restera et qui ne
réglera pas parce que le rire est au
dessus de plus de 100 euros par mois la
deuxième mais ça reste 9e paraissent la
deuxième dame le pen la deuxième année
que je ne veux plus de personnes vivent
en situation de handicap qu'ils soient
sans solution est donc je créerai tous
les postes d'auxiliaires de vie scolaire
pour que les jeunes enfants vivant en
situation de handicap puissent aller à
l'école je créerai les postes et les
structures pour que les enfants en
particulier des jeunes autistes n'est
plus à aller à l'étranger pour pouvoir
être en centre lorsqu'ils sont obligés
d'être en centre et je veux que nous
créions créeront les solutions concrètes
pour accompagner dans l'entreprise ou
les centres adaptés les personnes vivant
en situation de handicap ce sera l'une
des priorités de mon quinquennat
parce qu'aujourd'hui il y a des dizaines
de milliers de nos concitoyens au delà
des millions de personnes vivent en
situation de handicap et de leurs
familles qui sont sans solution livrée à
elle-même un quotidien on la porte on
n'apporte aucune réponse aucune
marine raison quel thème si vous êtes
tellement attaché au handicap d'ailleurs
vous devriez
regarder notre projet car avec nicolas
dupont aignan je crois que nous avons le
projet le plus complet le plus
comment dire qui tient compte de
l'intégralité des problématiques puisque
j'ai intégré dans mon projet la
proposition de nicolas dupont aignan
d'accorder une part fiscale pleine pour
un enfant qui est en situation de
handicap parce que il ya évidemment se
compromet et puis il ya ce qu'on ne
respecte pas monsieur macro et notamment
la loi de 2005 qui n'a jamais été en
réalité appliquée par aucun gouvernement
successifs pas plus celui auquel vous
avez participé que les autres et qui est
une attente de la part des personnes en
situation de handicap vous dites qu'il
faut des structures pour les enfants
autistes pour leur éviter de partir à
l'étranger c'est une évidence mais grâce
aux lancers lors cela fait des années
que ça doit être fait mais vous savez
les troubles du spectre autistique
ça permet à un immense majorité
d'enfants qui en sont frappés d'être à
l'école voilà et bien sûr l'école a été
repéré dans l'école tout à fait
classiquement et aujourd'hui les
socialistes qui ont donné beaucoup de
leçon de générosité en toutes
circonstances et bien laisse bien
souvent des ces enfants là en dehors de
l'école parce qu'on nous explique qu'il
ya pas assez de moyens alors il ya des
moyens pour financer l'immigration
massive
il ya des moyens pour financer l'aide
médicale d'état pour les clandestins qui
permet prendre en charge des soins
et de les rembourser bien mieux qu'on ne
les rembourse à des français en
situation difficile qui pourtant ont
cotisé toute leur vie puisque un
français sur trois ne se soignent plus
correctement aujourd'hui parce qu'il
n'en a plus les moyens parce qu'encore
une fois on ne réserve pas la solidarité
nationale à nos compatriotes le problème
c'est que la solidarité si elle n'est
pas national alors elle disparaît et
c'est exactement ce qui est en train de
se passer aujourd'hui nous n'avons pas
parlé d'un sujet mais ça que me souviens
qu'on s'intéresse plus et nous on est
les amis à lui jugé l'attitude de temps
d'antenne elena roger de l'immigration
est ce que c'est votre cas relance
français non à bâle mais là c'est pas
possible ce que vous savez on en est à
la seconde près et qu'on arrive à la
conclusion qu'on vous donne je vous
propose d une minute sur le thème que
vous avez choisi on redonnera un
minuteur réponse est ce que vous avez
répondu à sa carte blanche ce que disent
qu'il est votre droit d'ailleurs on est
ce qu'on vous parlait de lui thèmes que
vous ayez choisi pendant une minute s'il
vous plaît moi j'ai pas de thème choisi
c'est une philosophie générale monsieur
macron
la france que vous défendez ce n'est pas
la france c'est une salle de marché
dans lequel heures encore une fois c'est
la guerre de tous contre contre tous
dans lequel les salariés français
devront se battre pour conserver leur
emploi face aux travailleurs détachés
dans lequel les entreprises entre elles
dans la même branche devront se battre
pour avoir les salaires les plus bas ou
la durée de travail la plus longue pour
essayer de conserver les marchés entre
elles c'est absolument pas la vision qui
est la mienne moi je crois encore une
fois à la solidarité je crois que la
france est une nation avec une culture
avec un peuple avec
une espérance qui est l'espérance de
pouvoir continuer à
dans des conditions qui soient des
conditions respectueuses commercer avec
les autres nations du monde rétablir une
diplomatie la france a été jeté dans le
chaos mais par vos amis politiques par
ceux qui les ont précédés c'est à dire
en réalité par tous ceux qui vous
soutiennent dans cette campagne
présidentielle qui ont tous peu ou prou
une responsabilité dans la situation
actuelle il est largement temps de la
remettre en ordre et faire le choix de
la france et non pas le choix dans ce
territoire que vous souhaitez diriger
mais qui sera le lieu de toutes les
guerres en fait de tous les conflits et
de toutes les concurrences merci marie
noëlle pourrait peut-être de développer
cette vidéo que
nous allons donc vous avez plus de deux
minutes de traitement sévère tout le
temps est-ce que vous avez une
concurrence avec chacun deux minutes
sans vous interrompre pour faire votre
conclusion et cela a été tiré au sort
donc c'est vous qui conclurait madame le
pen vous prendra la parole avoir une
réponse on vient de vivre en dit long
sur ce que vous êtes on vous demande une
carte blanche
et vous salissez l'adversaire et vous
proférer des mensonges comme depuis le
début de ce débat parce que le pays vous
importe peu vous n'avez pas de projet
pour lui votre projet c'est de dire au
peuple français cette personne est
atroce et de salir c'est de mener une
campagne de mensonges et de
falsification votre projet
c'est un projet qui vise à vivre de la
peur et des mensonges c'est ce qui vous
nourrit c'est ce qui nourrit votre père
pendant des décennies c'est ce qui a
nourri l'extrême droite française est ce
qui vous a fait vous c'est pour ça que
je n'en veux pas pour mon pays parce que
la france que je veux elle vaut beaucoup
mieux que ça la france que je veux elle
ne sera pas diviser mais pour cela il
faut sortir en effet d'un système qui
vous a coproduit vous êtes la
coproduction du système que vous
dénoncez pas ce que vous en vivez vous
êtes sons parasites parce que
l'inefficacité des plats bien de droite
et de gauche classe la planification des
politiques de droite et de gauche cesse
front national qui s'en nourrit alors
moi j'entends la colère de nos
concitoyens je la vois sur le terrain je
la vis sans cynisme en tout cas sans le
vôtre mais je veux y apporter une
réponse en profondeur par une vraie
politique une vraie politique de
réformes de transformation du pays celle
qu'on n'a jamais fait depuis trente ans
en flag est avec moi pas la schlague
avec à nos concitoyens c'est pour ça que
lier pas ce genre de termes madame le
pen ça pourrait prêter à quelques
ambiguïtés venant de l'europe à la
schlague donc non pas chez moi si c'est
la construction qui vient du bas avec
les associations avec les territoires
dont on a trop peu parlé les initiatives
populaires mais des vrais transformation
des vrais changements pour lutter contre
le chômage pour l'école pour la
transformation du pays et surtout pour
sa réconciliation dans cinq ans si je
suis élu président jeune france que
ragagner la bataille face au terrorisme
face au chômage face à l'illettrisme
mais vous avez déjà récusé le medef et
la cgt j'appelle à voter pour nous à pas
parce qu'ils ne leur a pas les divisions
mais savait oui malheureusement les taux
et 6e appel aveux des bons va nourrir
moi je ne ris pas avec l'état de notre
pays ils m'inquiètent le medef et la cgt
est donc tout ce que je voulais au
lièvre que je ferai continuez votre
antienne madame le pen vous n'avez que
ça à la bouche vous n'avez pas de projet
pour le pays nos concitoyens l'ont vu ce
soir vous n'en avez pas et donc moi je
veux dans cinq ou ne veulent pas parce
que j'aurai et mac justement il a dit
j'ai lu ce vrai renouvellement frère
fait un vrai renouvellement des forces
griffe tous les socialistes s il vous
plait vrai visage nouveau ou les mines
une vraie force politique nouvelle pas
un parti d'extrême droite et des
socialistes des décennies justement
occupe la place avec des politiques qui
n'ont jamais été conduit avec je veux
une france avec estrosi veut une france
qui donnait bertrand avec nkm l'a
dit il mérite mieux
imerys à savoir la vérité la vérité je
la lui toujours et donnait alors qui
sera votre
s'arrête maintenant c'est là je réponds
et je termine à terminer ni vraiment
fait de manière très simple c'est que je
veux une france réconciliée tools
inverse de ce que vous porte alors et je
veux une france vraiment transformer les
pouvoir conclure à la seconde près voilà
alors maintenant vos conclusions à
chacun le principe ces deux minutes sans
s'interrompre ont fait qu'on vous fait
confiance
écoutez je crois que très clairement
enfin je veux dire la france
objectivement ce soir les français ont
pu voir exactement quel était le projet
de mai chez makro et quel était le mien
peut-être on dira que depuis ringarde
mais moi j'aime la france telle qu'elle
est cette france millénaire avec sa
culture avec son patrimoine avec salon
que vous voulez pas défendre avec sa
culture qui n'existent pas monsieur
macro avec ses frontières qui font que
s'il n'y a pas de frontières et bien il
n'y a pas en réalité deux pays libre et
indépendant
avec son peuple qui mérite d'être mieux
traités que encore une fois être jetés
dans une guerre fratricide qui vise à
permettre à certains d'obtenir un
maximum de profits pour eux mêmes ça
c'est la france que vous voulez vous
c'est à dire une france qui est ouverte
à tous les vents vous l'avez dit souvent
je suis candidat d'ouverture ballon vous
êtes le candidat de la fermeture des
fermetures d usines de la fermeture des
maternités de la fermeture des postes de
police de la fermeture des hôpitaux
voilà la seule chose que vous voulez pas
fermé c'est précisément les frontières
vous ne voulez pas que ce soit les
français qui est la clé de ses
frontières vous voulez livrer la france
à une immigration massive parce que les
grands patrons qui sont vos amis mais
ils attendent que ça d'ailleurs pour
pouvoir peser à la baisse sur les
salaires c'est pour ça que vous êtes
allé en algérie a réclamé une autoroute
migratoires enfin nous vendre une
autoroute qui grattent et l'algérie vous
êtes entre les mains des
communautaristes vous parler d'unité non
le le communautarisme c'est le contraire
de l'unité c'est le contraire de l'union
de la france et des français entre
monsieur macron c'est exactement le
projet qui vise à déstructurer notre
pays à l'affaiblir peut-être parce que
ça facilitera effectivement le travail
vertus sciences financières qui sont
auprès de vous et qui cherchent à tirer
profit de notre pays à se servir et non
pas bien entendu à le servir malherbe
kron madame le pen a utilisé sa
conclusion toute entière pour dire des
mensonges sur mon projet sans jamais
dire ce qu'elle voulait pour le pays je
ne veux pas de ça pour la france je ne
veux pas ça pour notre pays je ne veux
pas des profiteurs de l'échec et des
exploitants de la colère la france
mérite mieux sonne mieux que cela je
vous la france mon pays notre pays
il est aujourd'hui dans une crise
profonde qui est une crise morale qui
est un doute qu'il assure lui-même qui
est liée à l'échec de politique depuis
plus de 20 ans qui est l'échec aussi
d'une capacité à créer l'unité parce que
certains jouent de ses colères moi je
voudrais simplement dire que j'ai
entendu ses colères ses doutes ses
manques je veux y répondre par le
courage d'abord le courage de la vérité
je ne vous et moi jamais menti jamais
expliqué que j'allais vous faire des
cadeaux sans expliquer comment j'allais
les financer jamais vous promettre des
choses invraisemblables et le courage de
tenir nos engagements de nous tenir
fermement de tenir notre école
l'autorité dans celle-ci de tenir le
travail par lequel je veux une
émancipation notre langue que je défends
qui m'a fait je vous recommande de lire
mon livre et qui m'a fait grandir la
culture qui est la nôtre et qui partout
dans le monde et là notre pays qui a
toujours été forts dans une europe forte
et qui le protégera et dans un monde
ouvert pas ouvert à tous les vents un
monde où nous pouvons nous protéger
parce que nous aurons une politique
volontariste parce que nous aurons formé
nos concitoyens parce que nous aurons su
répondre à ces défis je refuse l'esprit
de défaites et de haine quand ron
thurlow front national je veux un esprit
de conquête avec des vraies réformes des
vrais changements nous le ferons
ensemble
mes chers concitoyens
mais nous le ferons en étant fidèles à
ce que nous sommes nous avons toujours
été un pays généreux un pays ouvert un
pays qui a été la lumière du monde et
pas le pays de l'obscurantisme mairie
cela ce que je veux c'est ce que là ce
que je mènerai merci à vous deux pour ce
débat on est françois hollande a
exactement 15 m le pen s'il vous plaît
non mais ça ne les suit pas commencé
pour moi ça dans un spectacle télévisé
le reste est resté à la même édition
avaient nimeiri boire dit la vérité moi
je veut présider le pays y comme vous
avez vous même fixé merci à 20,2 en tout
cas pour ce débat merci à vous qui
m'avez suivi nous espérons qu'il a
contribué à vous éclairer pour votre
choix de dimanche prochain bonne soirée
à vous tous au revoir merci
[Musique]